man it's getting crazy out there we got
an estimated 70 to 90 000 russian troops
amassing just near the ukrainian border
ukraine is responding the us and eu are
worried that russia will actually invade
ukraine and joe biden has apparently
threatened vladimir putin now
what we know definitively is that it's
like sanctions okay we're going to cut
you off from gas maybe the international
financial system but there's also we a
statement from sullivan who said that
you know we have deployments in europe
already and we're now looking at what
more deployments we might actually have
so he didn't want to say we're going to
send troops because we already have
troops there but maybe more but now it's
getting crazy because apparently there
is a republican who said we're not
taking nukes off the table boots on the
ground
yikes probably a really bad idea but
we're going to get into all that we've
got we've got images we've got photos we
have donald trump basically mocking him
being like mocking biden saying boo
doesn't care what biden's saying and
then we got this crazy story oliver
darcy saying the media is secretly
meeting with the bite administration to
collude on how to cover the failing
economy hey surprising isn't it chris
cuomo gets fired for his collusion with
a democrat his brother but this of
course is okay i'm glad hey look props
to darcy for reporting this then we got
elon musk saying that people need to
have more babies which would be pretty
interesting civilization is going to
collapse joining us to talk about all
this and probably a bunch of other stuff
is steve bannon
thanks for having me tim good to be back
i love the new studio appreciate it man
yeah i kind of i didn't have my you know
geospatially mm-hmm i didn't know where
i was when i was watching the tim poole
show
until i got everything's different it's
all different i didn't realize i said
where do you get the the acts and the uh
and everything but now see the whole
thing yeah it all makes sense with them
it's worth it
we have a an antique civil war rifle we
just found it in an antique store it's
crazy
it's a model 1861 colt percussion rifled
musket
uh never been fired mint boar
and i'm i'm stoked it's so cool it's a
union union weapon that was never
commissioned made from the silicon
valley of the uh early part of the
united states up in the connecticut
valley right
yeah
manufacturing yep megan weapons 10 000
were ordered but this one never got sent
out so it's it's it's almost i mean look
it's got you know 160 years of wear and
tear it's actually it's a model 1861
made in 1862 so pretty cool stuff but
steve thanks for hanging out and uh i
guess you know what how would you
describe yourself you know to someone
who's not heard of you there's a lot of
people who've never actually listened to
you that listen to us so i'm curious how
you describe yourself populist
nationalist traditionalist appreciate it
that's simple enough populist
nationalist
traditions believe power should be back
as close to the people as possible i'm a
ardent economic nationalist believe that
every country in the world should look
after its own self-interest and
traditionalist traditional values and
the traditional family but elon musk is
pumping for that's that's why i thought
that was interesting we'll talk about it
well we'll talk about it also because i
think the pr the prior announcement was
uh about putting chips in your brain
that was the misdirection plate oh by
the way we should have more robot babies
the big announcement was he wants to put
ships in everybody's brains by the fall
of 2022. is that what he said yeah no
it's coming in 2022. brain chips all
right well we'll get it
neurolink is going to have chips in the
minds of humans not not the lambs and
sheep you've seen them in the in the in
the pigs and all that stuff pigs pet and
pig no no no it's coming to human beings
by 2022 that was that was his big
announcement the misdirection play was
oh yeah we've got to you know we've got
to you know populate the earth by having
more wow
transhumanism tim i've been ranting and
raving and screaming about it for so
long
and i i definitely think uh the shirt
i'm wearing today is very appropriate
for our guest it's uh specifically
jailing people for victimless crimes the
unofficial slogan of the biden harris
presidential campaign comma looks really
ripped
she is she's a very strong lady
i knew it was the anarchist would get me
in trouble here
they're gonna come and get my ankle
bracelet right hey uh you know
i think you're right i don't think
you're wrong on that says and if you
want to support me and what i do you
could by getting the t-shirt on
thebestpoliticoshorts.com i also just
released a fauchi emperor palpatine
going after puppies and monkeys that's
also available i couldn't i couldn't fit
in the orphan's children i apologize to
the people out there nih experiments
orphan children look that up crazy
stuff's happening i'm excited for this
conversation thanks for having me ian
crossland over here happy to be in the
house what's up everybody and i am also
here pushing buttons with one of my
favorite guests we love having steve
bannon in the house love hearing about
what he's up to he's a fantastic
commentator i genuinely think he's like
the next rush limbaugh if you guys don't
listen to war room you definitely should
before transhumanism by the way it's one
of our biggest draws now oh yeah big
part of the show
we have a special editor nothing but it
oh it's cool oh yeah it's it's probably
it's it's the
actually interesting when you look at
the traffic it's one of the biggest
things that drives traffic because it's
such a serious topic are people into it
or scared of it both i mean we were
talking about smart dust we're talking
about all this other uh you know 20 30
new future technological advancements
it's it's it's i would say off stunning
but that's not a word
it's a great word it's uh it's crazy
what's happening globalization is the
misdirection play to take you off the
ball of the singularity that's the
singularities that's the signal not the
noise let's talk about it for sure
before we get started though head over
to timecast.com become a member and you
will get access to our exclusive members
only section where we have tons of
awesome conversations behind the scenes
um it's a special segment usually about
a half an hour with all of our guests
and we uh we swear a lot it's not very
family friendly but you definitely want
to check it out we'll have one up for
you around 11 or so p.m but also we just
hired another another journalist michael
robinson who's been writing a ton of
really awesome stuff and the more people
who sign up the more journalists we get
to hire the more work we get to do and
we need to launch new shows we started a
pop culture show we're going to be
actually launching i think our first
book should be ready before christmas
from tales from the inverted world so
it's cool i'm look i'm really excited
about the first book but i'm also kind
of antsy because the second book is
ghosts of the civil war our writer shane
went down to the to the south
investigating lost gold ghost stories
mysteries ufo sightings and he was
talking to people who are like he was
telling me he's like man they really
hate sherman down here so that's i'm
excited for that one that'll be our
second book but definitely this is all
thanks to your support at timcast.com
don't forget to like this video right
now if you're watching on youtube live
subscribe to the show share it right now
take that url paste it everywhere we're
talking about what's going on and if you
go to timcast.com and click store you
can get our step on snack and find out
shirt i'm very very much a big fan or
you can buy the poster that we made to
troll the entire country and continent
of australia it says visit howard
springs totally voluntary relocation
camp and it shows a police boat chasing
a guy while there's razor wire on the
beach and you can buy these and you can
you can basically just hang them up you
know wherever you think it's appropriate
for people to uh you know if you want to
show off in your storefront or something
or you know get that and let people see
it so with all that being said let's
talk about this first big story
i love this headline from axios it's
just three words biden threatens putin
wow that's that's amazing i say you know
journalism has come
yeah yeah well hey i mean that's a good
thing it's it's better than some
sensationalist 20 word title
uh we'll keep it simple in a video call
that lasted for just over two hours on
tuesday biden warned russian president
putin that if russia invades ukraine the
u.s will impose unprecedented sanctions
and provide additional weaponry to the
ukrainians national security adviser
jake sullivan said now axios doesn't
want to go as far as to say u.s troop
deployment because sullivan kind of
danced around it saying he doesn't want
to say we're bracing for you know
rotation of boots on the ground because
we already have rotational deployments
in the baltics but he is saying that is
entirely a possibility the us getting
involved in a ground war in ukraine
sound like a bad idea
sounds like a terrible idea particularly
on the 80th anniversary of pearl harbor
right so i think this is once again um
this is
the eu
has been pressing this fight forever
right they're the ones that talked about
the expansion of getting the ukraine in
this is where uh the the more radical
members of the eu and nato talked about
making ukraine a member of nato right
this has been pushing and pushing and
pushing forever uh biden's also doing
this for political expediency he needs a
wag the dog moment the wall street
journals polling came out today
absolutely horrific right he's i think
it's 26 percent right track wrong track
26 20 26 26
right track uh what 62 63 wrong track
you've got uh among uh people who think
he's doing great versus uh
terrible it's 37 to six these are
unprecedent unprecedented low numbers
not just not just on kamala harris on
him he has lost the country
okay and now he has no political capital
to support this orgia spending that's
going to bury everybody up on capitol
hill so he needs he needs to change the
conversation here's how he's going to
change the conversation he's going to be
a tough guy right he's going to push
around putin so
he's going to try to use this
to uh
purely for politics to try to get his
ratings up is his uh to show he's a
leader and this is a disaster and i
gotta tell you it's not just it's not
biting it's the uniparty
the worst comment of the day was not
from the pencil neck jake sullivan right
should they should be focused on the
chinese communist party and what's
happening in taiwan in the south china
sea with the center the worst comment
was from the senator from mississippi uh
wicker
who said everything's on the table
including combat troops not just the 200
advisers they have in there now combat
troops and tactical nuclear weapons a
nuclear strike i mean this guy's just
he's just it's he's blowing hot air come
on he's not blowing i'm not listen he's
a he's a very respected member he's a
very respected member particularly he's
on the armed services committee this guy
was on neil cavuto this is not this is
not a lightweight look he's in the
united states senator you have guys in
the united states senate say combat
troops and uh in in in tactical nuclear
weapons or a nuclear strike is not off
the table and you brought up a very
important point because historically
when the popularity of leaders goes down
you know history says that those leaders
start wars and conflicts and if there
was a conflict between the united states
and russia china would of course take
advantage of that situation invade
taiwan immediately and geopolitically
this is one of the worst situations that
the united states could make because we
should be working with russia aligning
with them and and establishing a better
relationship because there is a lot of
tension between russia and china
but with us going full force against
russia it's absolutely idiotic this was
trump's plan this is the reverse
kissinger nixon in 72. look you have the
you have the eurasian land mass okay
and right now american foreign policy
since 1914 has been we will never allow
one power or a series of power to
control central asia the eurasian land
mass the world island right because he
who controls the world island contr can
control the world
so and we so and think about it in 19 on
december 7th
of 1941 you had you had uh germany uh
italy the empire japan they just broke
up russia was a part of that that just
you know just come apart with the attack
today you have china pakistan iran
okay turkey
and with north korea north korea and
russia and we have forced those guys
into the into the chinese camp you talk
about internal politics putin needs this
too for his internal popularity and she
needs this you have three leaders all
for political reasons let's let's do the
mullahs in too yeah but steve i would
push back a little bit because during
the trump presidency trump sent lethal
weapons to ukraine something that even
obama was scared of doing and when you
look at his uh you know foreign policy
it was pretty much on par especially
when it came to bombing syria because
when we look at syria when we look at
yemen these are the proxy wars that are
happening between russia and the united
states and there might be another one in
ukraine ukraine might be i would say the
only guy in the national security
council that fought
tonight to not launch the uh the cruise
missiles into syria president trump did
not want to do that at the last minute
that was kind of an accommodation to the
uniparty but wasn't it ivanka trump who
also said that she was crying and then
it was trump's son who said it was her
that convinced them to bomb syria wasn't
that i don't i don't want to say that
but people were putting in front of him
you know about the children being uh the
chemical tax with gas which we found out
later was not true it was not true at
all and and his remember nobody's put
more pressure on putin than trump had
okay but you're right they i i think and
that was his um not acquiescing but i
think trying to work with the national
security apparatus
but he but but exactly you know morning
joe these guys david ignatius the next
day oh he's acting like a president
brian williams these missiles are
amazing and beautiful
they called them presidential and they
loved them they adored him this is what
mcmasters is about now of course biden's
not any better biden called putin a
killer recently and then a couple days
later he literally bombed a u.s aid
worker and killed seven children after
that so baden i think is even worse but
i think there's a coherent uh foreign
policy that has been steady against
russia uh throughout the last few
presidents
my youth i was you know on a on a
destroyer hunting soviet submarines in
the south china sea but it's so nobody's
more anti
uh anti uh soviet anti-communist and the
russians are run by kgb guys they're bad
guys that being said they should be an
ally
not an enemy we have a problem with
china right now trying to consolidate
the eurasian landmass and china is
coming at us on silicon valley west in
taiwan south china sea and against our
ally
india in the northwest frontier and
biden's done such a bad job with our
great ally india the front of the
financial times today is
wait for it putin and modi sitting there
hugging right cutting a deal because but
this is what president trump emoji
nobody could have been closer yeah
that's our central ally against
against china right with japan and and
here you got this thing is in total
disarray okay the american people have
voted about biden right now first off
you can tell 81 million people didn't
vote for him these polls mathematically
couldn't be this this low but these are
unprecedented numbers
in the 20s first of all if you get in
the 30s on the right track
but he but the polls have swung i mean
it started he's he started off this
collapses that collapses too much it's
just afghanistan was the start of the
collapse though
right so around around the i think that
i think that was a trick i think that
was a triggering mechanic i think it was
getting i think it was bad up until the
vet covered people i don't know which
way he was going i i do want to keep us
focused on uh on the foreign policy
stuff but i do want to say i think what
happens is like i said before uh last
time you were here trump was
anti-elected the the atlantic story stay
alive joe biden i think people voted for
joe biden because they didn't care and
didn't they they were convinced anything
was better than trump and they were
deceived and now they're realizing just
how awful of a mistake they made in
electing this guy and you see around
afghanistan when they're like he gave up
our air base but but i don't want to
rehash all that stuff i want to talk
about but you can see it in the ukraine
we're going to make the same mistakes
first off when you have people remember
wicker had been briefed okay he just
didn't walk into that interview cold he
had been briefed they've had discussions
and he said nothing should be off the
table that means they're actively
discussing
combat troops deployments to the ukraine
and they want to keep on the table his
word's not ours
tactical a nuclear strike but here's
what i want to mention you talking about
china it was i think pompeo who said
that china has infiltrated the u.s at
every level
every level we've seen numerous what
prof how many professors have been
arrested for basically giving away our
research to china double dipping china's
paying them the u.s is paying them
they're giving our research away i think
papaya was right and so i'm i'm
concerned about
when when when i read the story about
michael flynn and i think was he talking
to sally yates is that what happened and
he said i think russia is not a big
threat i think china is the bigger
threat then she panics she's like oh no
sounds to me like they are colluding
with china we know that don jr and biden
fly on air force two to go to that
private equity deal and now you're
wondering why i've got not done
i'm sorry sorry not don junior hunter
yeah
where's hunter i deeply apologize
hunter biden and his dad fly on the
plane to to china air force two air
force
in an official in an official capacity
don't get mad at me that was a mistake
no no but but in all seriousness uh
first of all four trillion dollars
you're for your audience understand
something your pension funds your
pension four trillion dollars of
american capital have gone into china to
finance it through larry finca this is
the collusion
of
of wall street and global corporations
you know the nba players called them out
the other day you had today apple
announced a what a 400 and 275 billion
dollar joint venture in china to help
their technological prowess have they
invested 275 billion dollars in the
heartland of this country to increase
the technological prowess of the united
states and the workers in the united
states no this is a company protected on
american soil and they're active partner
of the chinese communist party look to
make the system work does not conspiracy
make the system work you have to have
the slave labor of china the slave labor
of china and the state-owned industries
okay keep wages down throughout the
world that's why wall street and the
party of davos finance it yep that's how
they make the profits and they want to
make china the rest of the world and it
was the henry kissinger david
rockefeller policy that in the 70s
instituted all of this and literally has
set it up for the global world they want
china to be the rest of the world social
credit score surveillance states smart
cities smart grids all of that it's
first being implemented in china and
it's going to be implemented in the
united states and now we're going to get
bogged down remember
let's put in perspective china's the
great the chinese communist party is the
greatest enemy we've ever had the
largest economy the most sophisticated
right that one with the deepest culture
what five thousand years ten thousand
years
russia
is this economy is the size of new york
state okay it's the size of new york
state and it's imploding it's a
death spiral they don't make any
technology we want they got great
hackers and you know what they got they
got natural gas that the germans and
others want right the gdp of italy so
exactly exactly and yeah and yet we're
going to put you have a u.s senator a
republican and this is one thing i want
to say is a populist and a nationalist
this is the type of neocon this is the
type of neocon ism that has destroyed
the republican party and helped to
destroy this country that you know this
nine trillion dollars we spent in iraq
and afghanistan over 20 years and what
the ten thousand or twelve thousand
combat casualties or the the killed in
actions plus the forty to fifty thousand
casualties is because that thinking
wicker's thinking today oh everything's
on the table boots on the ground combat
troops and a nuclear strike so i want to
kind of wrap this all together
we we we heard from pompeo we've been
infiltrated by china sure joe biden's
rate his approval ratings are in the
trash he needs some kind of combat so he
points at russia because he knows russia
has no real threat
and he doesn't care about china or at
the very least he wants china to succeed
in the media remember in washington dc
in in remember the first impeachment
trial russia is like you know they i
want to call the 1980s and get get their
foreign policy back russia is considered
a 50 times bigger enemy than the chinese
communist party and one of the reasons
the money the chinese county's party has
spread all over town but the journalists
and all that russia is
a zero okay it is in a demographic
despot and it's pr don't get me wrong
they're bad guys run by the kgb with
lots of nuclear weapons okay and and
they've got troops but this situation in
ukraine
is a european situation that they force
it on us
and and to do it on the e on the uh
commemoration of pearl harbor right i
think is i think is extraordinary for
him to do that let me pull up this story
look at the exact quote here we have
this from mediaite gop senator floats
u.s troops on the ground and nuclear
strike against russia quote i would not
rule that out senator roger wicker of
mississippi told neil cavuto on tuesday
the u.s shall keep should keep all
options available when dealing with a
potential russian aggression against
ukraine that even includes a first use a
preemptive nuclear strike
that senator appeared on fox news hours
of the teleconference between biden and
putin quote
senator some of your republican
colleagues think that we should have
troops in the region they never
delineate exactly how many or that
they'd be utilized in an outright
confrontation with russia over ukraine
but their mere presence would be
effective what do you think of that i'll
tell you this neil said wicker i would
not rule out military action i think we
start making a mistake making a mistake
when we take options off the table so i
would hope the president keeps that
option on the table cavuto presses what
does military action mean he says well
military action military action could
mean that we stand off with our ships in
the black sea and we reign destruction
on russian military capability it could
mean it could mean that we participate
and i would not rule that out i would
not rule out american troops on the
ground he added we don't rule out first
use nuclear action we don't think it
will happen but there's certain things
in negotiations if you're going to be
tough you don't take off the table and
so i think the president should say that
everything is on the table
do you know steve
the current
power uh uh uh uh how do i have this
question um the web the nuclear bombs we
used in world war ii
do you know how many times stronger a
modern and nuclear uh icbm is
1250 times more powerful a multiple
independently targeting re-entry vehicle
mirv can drop 12 payloads from one icbm
it is laughable how insane that
destruction would be from one how many
does russia have they got what like 50
000 the us has what 25 this is the type
of loose talk there's one thing about
negotiating and leverage this is the
type of when you actually put on the
table a first strike
over ukraine
this country is going to go to war over
eastern ukraine yeah what is russia this
is what this is what we're going to do
and a killing field in world war ii what
15 million died on the way when the
nazis went through and 12 million died
on the way back right
and they were fighting for each side you
couldn't tell who was fighting for whom
no this is
think about it for a second
if people had a belly full of iraq in
afghanistan in 20 years in in the great
deplorable sons and daughters who fought
there and my daughter was after west
point went to iraq she deployed to iraq
and i can tell you as a parent you you
know how little power you have in life
when you're praying every night that
they just come home in one piece
think about it for a second just after
extracting ourselves from there because
the american people said no more told
the elites you know and he did a
terrible job of getting out but we've
got to get out of saying president trump
want to do from day one to know that
they could be having a conversation on a
guy at a high level in the senate that's
been briefed a republican and you can
put on the table combat troops and first
strike nuclear what are we talking about
yeah that's absolutely insane and before
the show started when we were talking
about ukraine i compared it to
uh europe's own kind of afghanistan
there's no winning or losing in in
ukraine it's only death especially when
you look at the larger history of what
happened there and today the ukrainian
government had a military parade the
ukrainian defense minister said that
this is going to lead to a bloody
massacre he's warning europe about 5
million refugees and he's not wrong
russia is making a very strong stance
here they're saying that they want a
legal guarantee that ukraine will never
join nato or become a base for weapons
that can target russia and they are
saying very strongly that they will
guarantee this themselves if they have
to they don't want to there's a two-hour
call between biden and putin who's of
course relationships are very tethered
especially after biden started attacking
him publicly but there's also plans for
future talks luckily luckily we're still
in the phase of diplomacy and we need
more of that
far be it for me
to go back to hunter biden but it
shouldn't be lost on people that biden's
you know gig with barisma that whole
nightmare right was the russian thing
these guys have been skimming money off
the crooks in ukraine for decades okay
the clinton foundation the clinton
global initiative they've been out there
with their handout with these guys you
can't trust any of them a pox on all
their houses and the american people
cannot be sucked in to what brussels
brussels have been forcing this raheem
kassam's done some incredible reporting
he was there back in 15 i think when
they had the color revolution or 2 13
when they had the color i was there as
well
exactly so my point is you've been there
why are we in 2021 with all the problems
we had and we just extracted ourselves
out of here that now we're talking about
an active deployment when we got our
hands full no to the bite administration
in that pencil neck j sullivan you got
enough problems show me you have a plan
in the south china sea and around taiwan
because if we lose taiwan you're not
going to get a ford f-150 for five years
okay
i want to pull this up from wikipedia
roger wicker is on the senate committee
on armed services
that's the biggest of the bill that's
the armed services committee right
because you have the pascacoola naval
base you know stenit and all those guys
i think that's important to point out
big time he's not some guy wandering
around this guy's brief to get the
highest security clearances he got
briefed on that he said they are
actively
running models
i'm not saying they're going to do it
but i'm saying you look at the spectrum
of things that nothing should be off the
table guys in the pentagon in the
national security apparatus are running
scenarios
he said it scenarios where is he going
to have a first strike tactical nuke and
you're going to have american combat
troops is this are the russians do they
want the ukraine for them to annex it or
something i know he annexed crimea or
they ukraine was very close to russia
with this fear of sphere of influence
they actually say that eastern ukraine
they would actually argue as part of
russia doesn't ukraine just mean
borderlands
yes that's that's what i was told when i
was in ukraine against borderlands
that's what they called the ukraine now
the people of ukraine say drop the the
and just call it ukraine because we're a
country yeah they changed the spelling
of kiev too and then there was a lot of
u.s intervention and a lot of
non-profits that got involved in ukraine
and there was a revolution that was
orchestrated and that of course turned
ukraine from being corrupted by russia
to being corrupted by the european and
nato side and now there's still
corruption in ukraine because the
revolution was all based on corruption
that corruption has still continued to
this day and some people would argue was
even made worse by this larger
transition quote revolution
biden just counted look he had the
four-hour meeting with washi beforehand
he said you know on the stage he said oh
we're gonna we're gonna defend taiwan he
had the four-hour meeting never mention
the wuhan you look at the two readouts
you look at the beijing readout you look
at the u.s readout not one mentioned in
four hours of the wuhan lab or the ccp
virus not one second to mention he
cow-towed they and he came out and said
oh we're a firm believer in the one
china policy the taiwan's a a region of
uh
of of china and eventually will be
reunited we believe in the we have the
one china policy he cow towed he's
gutless in
china and now he's trying to show his
commander-in-chief bravado in against
russia in the ukraine this is another
disaster it's somewhat it's it's that
insecure bully on the playground who's
like i'm going to prove i'm tough by
picking on a little kid where's corn pop
when we need him
it's funny i mean look obama called uh
called russia a regional power remember
that yeah they they were a regional
power that's what they are but you know
they aspire to be a world power like
they used to be but they're not because
did i mention that the economy is the
size of new york state and they're in a
demographic death spiral when obama said
this it was seen as a slight yes you
know he was disparaging uh because he
knew putin wanted to bring back the
soviet union that power and he couldn't
and he was you know he was basically
being like look at us with the big dogs
and here's the regional power russia
should be our ally in breaking up this
this uh this iran pakistan uh turkey uh
run by the ccp
trying to consolidate uh the uh the
eurasian land mass they should be an
ally we have forced them right and like
i said they're not good guys don't
they're not good guys but the enemy of
my enemy is my friend and they could
have been the enemy of our enemy which
is the chinese cameras i don't know i
don't i don't like that you know that
the idea but i do i do think it's fair
to say the enemy the enemy of my enemy
can certainly work how to work out an
agreement with me in dealing with our
mutual act how do we win world we
wouldn't world war ii with joseph stalin
and if we hadn't had this there was
russians to take 25 chameleon combat
casualties we were never defeated hitler
and mussolini in the time we it took to
to to uh to destroy him remember but
just for your audience today's the 80th
commemoration of pearl harbor
franklin roosevelt went i think tomorrow
technically and declared war that date
the lives and infamy declared war
tomorrow 80 years ago on the imperia on
the empire of japan he did not declare
war on nazi germany or the the italian
fascist hitler declared war on us the
next day because he had a secret treaty
and he thought we were weak he thought
we were all talking no action meanwhile
we were building nuclear weapons and
sending lots of money and weapons to the
british but they were they were they
were also working on nukes too weren't
they we just beat them to it i mean they
they were developing very very very
close that's why they had the heavy
water in norway yeah that's why
and that's why after the war
we took a lot of their scientists and
the russians did as well so the russians
are scientists i believe they
experimentally veered away from nuclear
research into the vr to rocket research
so that they could start hitting the
cruise missile and then because of that
they didn't get the nukes in time bad
decision but they would have yeah
because the blitzkrieg was that the
zeppelins over over london was that what
it was yes so if they had if they had
gravity bombs and if they focused on
gravity bomb research instead of cruise
missiles they were wiped out and i could
tell senator wicker the last time the
first and only time tactical news were
ever used
is in is it after the end of a three and
a half year one of the bloodiest wars
ever had in the pacific right because
the japanese would not surrender the
kids and yet he's he's sitting there
with the pentagon think about it they
are running scenarios tonight as we talk
about putting combat inserting combat
troops i'm not going to say they're
doing it but they're thinking about it
they're not taking it off the table so
they're thinking now and modeling combat
troops to join nato and this eu army
right this eu military thing that the
french are trying to put together in the
ukraine and they're modeling tactical
nuclear strikes i did a lot of research
on modern nuclear weapons for the
segment i was actually doing with
discovery uh like you know
discovery networks and uh i gotta say
like it was shocking how little people
who are like millennials for instance
understand the rapid technological
advancement in nuclear weapons
capability the the difference and i will
say this again between what we used in
world war ii that was a gravity bomb
what that means is it was a big bomb we
dropped it out of a plane since then
we've created intercontinental ballistic
missiles
multiple independently targeted re-entry
vehicles carrying 12 warheads with 1
250 times the explosive power and you
know what else i learned did you know
the radiation is on purpose yes when a
nuclear bomb goes off and it radiates an
area that's intentional yes there's
actually russian nuclear bombs that do
not irradiate areas and the us has
similar ones too i was when we were
doing this research we looked at the
simulation of which kind of weapon used
by which country what would the level of
devastation be the initial incendiary
wave the the sonic the the shock wave
and the radioactive uh area and
and and what they do is i think the new
york times did this it was over
manhattan what would happen in manhattan
and you would pick like i'll use the you
know the russian whatever missile and it
shows a wave of fire just incendiary
wipes out from from from river to river
in new york but there's also lower uh
kiloton bombs that heavily irradiate the
area that when we talk about nukes
people need to understand this a nuclear
strike on russia could mean a lot of
things it could mean destroying that
area for hundreds of years and and it's
not just nuclear weapons that we have to
worry about since of course vladimir
putin even hinted at uh biological
weapons natural disaster weapons and
also artificial intelligence weapons as
of course vladimir putin on the world
stage a couple years ago came out and
said
artificial intelligence is going to be a
lot more powerful and lethal than
nuclear weapons himself he also said
that the country that leads the world in
the development of artificial
intelligence will be the ruler of the
world so these are the types of
situations that we're dealing with that
is even far more complex than nuclear
weapons which on the base level are
we're just beginning i'm no error i'm
not eric schmidt fan but the paper they
put up for the defense department a year
ago and it came out with this book with
kissinger recently but the paper they
came up with a year ago said the exact
same thing said that there's an arms
race now on on ai and a i will ai will
be the future there's already all types
of weapons that you can see the future
if you have a smart enough
artificial intelligence that can
calculate probabilities and variables in
in the proper way looking at all the
data from social media they can they can
predict things i would imagine it would
be able to control drones turn them
around drop bombs on their other targets
missiles shut off
let's talk about biological weapons look
what came out of wuhan we know
was part of the pla's ccp's biological
weapons program okay that was being
researched at the time so you could have
all types of biological weapons
ukraine
is a scab you don't want to pick okay
because there's going to be a lot of pus
coming out of there i want i want to
point out an easy way for people to
understand the power of artificial
intelligence take a look at what they're
talking about with self-driving cars you
know i've got a tesla i could sit down
and i you you pull the thing down twice
the car drives itself
now what they're talking about is we're
not going to need like you know the road
signs we have and all these things we
don't need them you're not going to need
any road signs because the cars talk to
each other so when two cars are coming
at each other you don't need it you
don't need lanes the cars just know how
far apart to be and once all cars are
smart look at what they can do and
predict and how they can move around now
think about the weaponization
capabilities of that you will they will
be able to use social media data
communications technology to predict
exactly where someone will be we've long
joked and i know this is this is meant
to be silly that facebook knows when you
poop they literally do they there was an
article talking about how facebook can
predict based on how long you've been
sitting in one place when the last time
you you got food was that they know when
you will go to the bathroom and they
predict that now imagine you've got a
military general oh they can predict
when you poop they can also predict
where you'll be when you'll be there
they can effectively see the future and
then they can just say drop a hellfire
missile and you know what we got an 87
chance of him actually being there
that's going to be the future of ai
warfare it would be terrifying or just
get uh people's dna and then you know
what they're predispositioned to get
injured from or allergic to or affected
by and this is one reason why the
chinese have been doing their damnedest
to get as many covet tests as they can
back to china so they could uh harvest
the dna of all the americans and there's
also other crazy incidences
what's the source on that there's this
is the fbi according to the la county
sheriff who came out and said that he's
not going to be participating with the
covet test because they're linked with
to a company that's connected to china
that is data harvesting and taking
people's dna but that's one of the
source we have the source uh just keep
talking like i gotta go julian another
things to say i'm like i'm like
i feel like emperor probably it's just
real quick i want to be very careful
because when we say things that you know
yes there's gonna be a lot of
particularly in this area right i'm
telling you when people listen this on
itunes or whatever they're gonna be like
what npr
february 24th 2021 china wants your data
and may already have it this is talking
about kovid and they they said that okay
s covet case is going to rise a chinese
company contacted several u.s states and
offered to set up testing labs as a
byproduct the chinese firm beijing
genomics institute would likely gain
access to the dna of those tested
february 24 2021 from all things
considered npr this is as mainstream
corporate press as you get china is
getting your dna yes and when they get
your dna they could game the big pharma
market but also in the in the kind of
levels of uh dirty bombs or biological
weapons they could lead the world in
setting off something on the world that
could only affect a specific amount of
populations with a specific gene
sequencing so the level of warfare that
we're dealing with i would say we are
already at war but information fifth
generational warfare is a lot more
powerful than bullets and steve correct
me if i'm wrong i don't know if you know
about this or not there was also a lot
of crazy incidences reported with
american ships uh nuclear uh ships
literally just being turned off and a
lot of the people not knowing what was
going on by cyber attacks yes not just
cyber attacks but also just in the water
and then something flies over and then
and then the military ships are just
turned off and they can't uh turn on
there's also some theories about aliens
intervening and stopping nuclear warfare
so there's a lot of different things out
there i'm just interested in what you
heard about it personally being inside
of the white house real quick on that we
had we had those stories about those
lights those weird drones or whatever
following the battleships it's very
likely these are just
this is just technology that exists
technology or whatever who knows what it
is we don't need specific technology
exists that can disable our what's your
clearance
something practical something practical
i think you're going to see polling
that's going to come out i think that
people are going to get in to start
polling
and if biden thinks his numbers are low
now
wait to wait to they start pulling
people on do you support going sending
combat troops to the ukraine where's the
ukraine where is that again this is this
is the uniparty this is the elites that
rule us
so far ahead of the american people
because you know what hunter biden and
hunter biden's kids aren't going to be
their wickers kids are not going to be
there okay this is once again the
deplorables that are going to get
deployed to a part of the world we've
got no business in i i think it's fair
to say mostly it will be the deplorables
children 100 but but i will say i want
to stress there's going to be a lot of
regular poor working-class families who
are going to suffer from this it's not
just the deplorables
our poor working-class families that's
what i said start calling them the
deployables no no but look look the
deplorables
was used as a reference to like you know
the people who are supporting the
populist movement trump specifically but
there's going to be you know 100
politically uninitiated regular
americans who working-class americans
and the poor and the the sons and
daughters of the poor that's just going
to get so they don't care remember
that you said they don't care no no no
no no no no encourage it no the elites
don't care
what i mean is i would actually take it
one step further and say the elites want
and encourage the poor to be shipped off
to go fight anywhere
it's not that they don't care it's that
they revel in it
that's why people have to stand up and
say no more no moss this is this is
absurd there's an intentional
they want the americans and the russians
to fight so that the chinese take
like uh currency control basically you
think this is the davos i think the
davos have a have this hatred because
remember uh the soviet union and a lot
of these cultural marxists and people
that associate these things still
would love the soviet union to be around
they hate putin because he's a
nationalist
right he's he's very traditional
okay it's a lot of reasons they sell
salvini and a lot of people a pen and
the people in europe you know like him
because he's more or
are
fine they have an affinity to him
because of his uh his nationalist
tendencies it's one of the reasons the
uniparty hates him and like i said
they're bad guys they're all from the
kgb they're all oligarchs it's
completely a corrupt system right uh
it's a country in a demographic death
spiral
economy the size of new york doesn't
make anything technologically that the
world wants but it's got some of the
best hackers in the world right
and so and by the way tons of nuclear
weapons very sophisticated on december
syrian hackers were actually based in
moscow when the soviet union split did
all the nukes go to russia or most of
them go to russia they go all over the
place the only ones i think that didn't
go to russia were the ones in kazakhstan
i think the guy that the ruler of
kazakhstan is the only guy that that
really you know turned them into
plowshares right the rest of the rest of
them all went back to the uh to to
basically russia they don't think
anybody else got rid of the guy in
kazakhstan but look the kgb guys are
dangerous but the uniparty hates putin
but that's one of the reasons putin is
uh
is butting up to the ccp now they've got
that unified thing they've gotten and
look we're hitting three
geopolitical crisis at the same time you
have the south china sea and in taiwan
actually have the northwest frontier in
india you've got this nuclear deal with
the iranians that that is totally coming
unwound and now you've got the ukraine
and all these are we're forcing this
we're forcing these except for what we
should be forcing which is taiwan in the
south china sea and we gotta we gotta
that that's that's we gotta take a stand
in taiwan if we lose taiwan what's
silicon valley west what's the northwest
frontier in india that's that's up in
afghanistan that's where pakistan yeah
in the himalayas
have been fighting each other for about
two years and by the way i think they're
kind of on i think i what i hear is that
the indian army is a much higher alert
up there than they're letting on
that's been that's a friction point and
think about it the ccp has come down and
surrounded india down in burma right or
miramar with that revolt there so
they're trying to isolate india india is
the key that picks the lock in our
indo-pacific
strategy what happens come you know
trump is do you think trump's running
again i know he's running again he's
going to win again so trump's
he's going to win the presidency for the
third time can i say that on youtube
he's going to win the presidency he's
going to win the presidency for the
third time in 2024. well trump is not
the president joe biden is the president
an illegitimate president and if donald
trump runs again do you think
india comes on you know comes in and
works in the mind we know that modi and
trump were good friends yes and they're
both nationalists and i think that yes
modi and trump
the biggest event trump's ever had in
the country was howdy modi down i think
it was in houston 50 000 people yeah
right i mean modi and trump are very
close and not just that we're closely
aligned right they he understands that
trump is the one one person has ever
stood up to to to
to to the chinese countries party trump
is running in 2024
trump is going to win in 2020
i think i i i nothing your audience has
blown up
well well as soon as you bring up the
election stuff we are completely
obligated to address it okay we
absolutely have to we'll be deleted off
youtube in two seconds because of what
because of that conversation and so
uh what i'll say is i it's frustrating
for me the the level of optimism that i
know i don't want to tell people not to
be optimistic but in 2020 and and we
talked about this in the members segment
last time you were here when i when my
skateboarder friends who work on minimum
wage and can't tell you the name of not
even one supreme court justice let alone
define what it is our posts are making
tick-tock videos of them voting by mail
and then i'm going back to like my
friends and all of them are like
fervently supporting joe biden today
some of these people have left the
country
wow so it's i just it's
the the the crew the skateboard crew
i know a couple people who have already
left the country
and it's not necessarily because they
were like oh no but in so bad it's more
like wow like
this is not a fun place to live i need
to find something better and i don't
think they correlate their actions in
supporting joe biden in 2020 with what's
happening now so i will just stress
in my experience you know we had um
uh i know you and i disagree with this i
want to say tell youtube that tim is
adamant that joe biden won he's been
adamant about it and so it's a deeply
held belief of yours it's it's look i'm
not going to pretend like i have all the
answers to everything but i will say
that when we've had our conversations
with people like like matt brainard
several times uh there's there's there's
always been uh here's what we think not
here's what we know and so my attitude
is
what republicans have done poorly is
ground game and i'll tell you i think
one of the one of the biggest impacts on
the 20 20 2020 election was universal
mail-in voting not because of any kind
of fraud i certainly think like what
bill barr said yeah there's fraud you
know we don't think there's that you
know is there enough and i've not had
anybody come to me you know you've got
wild wild crazy accusations from people
like lindell and and sydney powell but
when it comes to the more like you know
we want to do a forensic audit nothing
definitive has come out to the point
where it's been laid out but but i will
say this i want to keep you on youtube
let's have that conversation in your in
your in your silent behind the wall chat
or some other time because i can walk
you from wisconsin to georgia to to to
maricopa to maricopa county not too late
tonight but we'll do i'll get navarro
and we'll walk you through the whole
thing chapter and verse we did have we
had navarro here too yeah definitely we
should we should do a big conversation
but i will say this
one thing to consider absolutely um
first i have my anecdotal evidence being
someone from chicago and knowing tons of
people who uh weren't just the the the
they couldn't tell you what supreme
court justice meant they're like i don't
know what that is and i'd be like okay
well like seriously they don't yeah
these are these are minimum wage workers
they skateboard they don't understand or
want to understand but i'm watching
these people post videos one guy filmed
himself in first person with his mailing
ballot to go and i'm like these people
were absolutely they were locked down
for a year the only thing they ever
heard was orange man bad over and over
again and everything that you're
suffering from is his fault here's what
i think happens
when you have a dense urban population
like new york city where you've got
these big buildings with you know a
thousand people live in it you can get
two democrat activists to go
door-to-door and say see that mail-in
ballot sign it fill it out i'll wait but
when you're talking about republican
voters in suburbs or i'll just take that
mail-in ballot and i'll fill it up for
you perhaps but republicans can't do
that you're in a suburb you're going to
go drive door to door the amount of
houses that a republican on ground game
could get to to advocate for universal
mail and voting is substantially lower
substantially orders of magnitude lower
dense urban populations where you don't
need to walk more than 20 feet to knock
on the next family's door whereas in
rural areas you might have to drive
maybe like two or three blocks to get to
the next house that is the level of
ground game that i think needs to be
focused on when they come out and they
say the shadow campaign and here's what
we did i think it's very important you
pay attention to that and keep that in
mind moving into the next election and i
agree with mike cernovich too when trump
came out and started talking about all
this fraud it was effectively voter
suppression because they convinced
people not to go out and vote so i look
at this two ways
we've had multiple people on talk about
this i have not been convinced and we
and and then we've also seen the
detriment to other to future elections
because of the narrative that there's no
point and i think that is something we
need to avoid so that's why i'm kind of
like let's just tell people that's
that's why that's why you gotta get to
the bottom of three november you get to
the bottom of three in november you saw
this in in in virginia
we had 95 see this is the false
narrative of the left today they're all
on you know msnbc all day they got the
long faces because why we're getting
people to take over school boards we're
getting people to sign up to be precinct
committee men we're getting people to
take over election boards and to take
over the the county clerkships either
volunteer or by voting but you know
democrat all democracy all small d
democrat and they can't they can't stand
it they have every part they have every
branch of government they have the media
they have high culture low culture
middle culture pop culture universities
all of it and they're freaked out
because the american people now are
stepping up and doing this in virginia
we had 95
participation in as election officials
and by poll watchers 95 percent in 2020
33 percent the last gubernatorial race
27 percent the republicans are not going
to allow ever again not with new laws we
don't need new laws but to get to the
bottom of november third and to make
sure that never happens to us again okay
i i say it this way remember last last
november in november 2020 we had
sweeping victories across the country
villages in connecticut
miami we had we had we had long island
the villages of connecticut you had you
had the county prosecutor the city
prosecutor in seattle i i think we
should definitely do a much longer issue
because i don't want to i don't want to
detract from the news we're talking
about but i do have to say okay when you
see the suburban housewives voting
republican in virginia what was it like
a 30-point swing
they don't like trump man i i think it's
you see this victory for the republican
in virginia when it's not trump but it's
it's a lot of the same but this is also
the orange man bad thing i think it's
over the other thing is people they i
think they can live with mean tweets now
okay
that's what the 26
right track wrong track with the two
hand the right track with the two handle
in front of it it's unheard of yeah
nixon when he when nixon walked across
the lawn and took the helicopter out of
there i think it was 2 30 i think it was
still 33 or 35 percent approval he
wasn't in the 20s people are seeing
recklessness
they're seeing uh incompetence and most
importantly they're seeing that they
don't they don't respect us you've seen
everything that happened on capitol hill
look at this thing with ukraine all
sudden
ukraine comes out of nowhere and in 24
hours we're talking about maybe tactical
nuclear weapons right there's no respect
for the american people to sit there and
say hey here's our plan here's our
policies here's what we're trying to
accomplish here let's do this uh so we
we i think we disagree on on only some
but i want to have a conversation with
you we'll do this in the member segment
where you can walk us through well not
santa tonight i'll get i want to get
navarro and take time on your members
section we'll walk through we'll bring
them we'll bring the charts to the state
i think it's something you guys see
graphically but you can actually go
through the details in wisconsin another
thing and people can understand what we
say about well i want to talk about
another really big factor and what's
going on today and what also went down
in 2020 and that's media collusion
because we have this tweet from oliver
darcy uh um look hey man shout out to
oliver darcy for actually putting this
out here he said some news in reliable
sources senior white house and admin
officials have been holding briefings
with major newsrooms over the past week
as they try to reshape economic coverage
the white house not happy with the
news's media coverage of the supply
chain and economy has been working
behind the scenes trying to reshape
coverage in its favor senior white house
and edmond officials including nec
deputy directors david kamen and bharat
rama rama murti along with port's envoy
john porcari have been briefing major
newsrooms over the past week a source
tells me the officials have been
discussing with newsroom trends
pertaining to job creation economic
growth supply chains and more the basic
argument that has been made the
country's economy is in much better
shape than it was last year i'm told the
conversations have been productive with
anchors and reporters and producers
getting to talk with officials to put it
simply they're having secret meetings
behind your back because they want the
press to change their narrative on the
garbage economy and you're suffering
this is what they did with uh
afghanistan he wanted the afghani
president to tell everyone things were
going just just fine
white houses do white houses do
background briefings to people to make
sure they can understand the
complexities of of issues right and help
the media be smart and win the dresses
that is not what this is this is the
fact that they have now spent how many
trillions of dollars
on bills that they've passed to juice
this economy
and it's dead if you take the printing
machine away from these clowns this
economy is going to implode and they
know it okay that's why they're up there
today with the with mitch mcconnell and
the republicans doing a gimmick to get
relief on the debt ceiling okay now what
darcy's outing them on is that they're
back now because they got to have the
media work with them to sell it to the
american people remember they're talking
on the talk shows all week the media is
not or saki said the media is not doing
you're not doing a good job of selling
our program
now they need a media partner to sell it
okay because every time you see anything
with metrics like the jobs report last
week which was what less than half of
what the jobs were and people can
remember this is with a massive infusion
of cash
they say it's oh different than last
year yeah you had another with three
trillion dollars another what two and a
half or three trillion dollars has been
juiced into the system okay and yes it's
a lot worse than last year have you seen
this before i can't i don't know the m1
money supply oh yeah yeah right there i
love it i love it right around the
starts of the uh the pandemic they they
instituted a change in reporting where
they said your savings accounts are now
basically checking accounts which causes
the money supply to explode by by
several hundred percent but what
they try and argue they always say to me
tim you don't understand that huge spike
is just a change in reporting because
savings are now and okay well look at
since then look at this this spike we
went from what do we got here
five hundred 16
eighty-three and that's in what billions
i think it is billions of dollars
and now it's at twenty thousand billions
of dollars in the span of what we got we
got from june 2020 until october of 2021
we have jumped 4 000 billion dollars in
the money supply
this is fiat money this is the reason
they have forced you i tell people it's
it's you right now every and i'm not
telling you to buy gold and silver or
platinum and i'm not telling you to buy
crypto but here's what i am telling you
you on your own have better get smart on
your own sit there do your study talk to
people because they're forcing you
they're destroying the us dollar in
front of our eyes and they're destroying
you for generations to come if they get
the spending done the seven trillion
dollars programmatically that you can't
take back every person in this audience
under 45 years old you better start to
look for another store of value than the
us dollar you either got to look at
precious metals or you got to have to
look at crypto because they've destroyed
it's their this is the machine the
machine right now is out of control and
you can see look let's let's be let's
talk facts look at this gimmick tonight
the one piece of leverage the
deplorables have is the debt ceiling
right they got to come to you and get 60
votes and kind of push the debt ceiling
that they've got you've got them by the
short and curlies and so tonight as we
sit here they've got a gimmick up there
to do it with 51 votes so they they
increase it the republicans don't not
don't have to take any hits for it it
can go on they need and remember they
can't sell enough bonds to the to the
japanese into the chinese or to the
insurance companies right they can't
raise taxes taxes all revenues to the
government's around three three and a
half trillion dollars right they need
that huge gap which is a train and a
half dollars a year
in perpetuity
plus all these other crazy programs that
are half-baked and they haven't thought
through that comes from printing money
okay and that is on people think it's
free it's not free it's the full faith
and credit
of the united states of america that
would be this audience okay that is on
your shoulders okay and and
that is what's going to destroy us it's
out of control and the uniparty takes
care of themselves that's why you have
wicker up there saying yeah we're
thinking about combat troops and
tactical nuclear weapons the uniparty
the party of davos the wall street the
global world corporations and the guys
they paid in in washington d.c what do
you think happens to property value
well i think right now that's why i
think look with zero interest rates this
is the scam they have interest rates
artificially low near zero the assets
are increased that's why you had the
concentration coming off of the uh
the crash in 2008 the greatest
concentration of wealth because what
they did they took the balance sheet of
the federal reserve from 880 million
dollars to 4.5 trillion infused it with
liquidity the system with liquidity
assets expi
blow up
trump called in 2012 best time to buy
stocks or real estate it's coming right
now the same things happen this is why
we've had this greatest concentration of
wealth ever
since since the ccp virus and it's going
to continue for the as soon as they stop
as soon as they cut the machine off
the stock market will collapse so for
the average person who's listening they
got a mortgage on their house you know
35-year mortgage or a 30-year mortgage
or whatever what does this mean to them
and their and their mortgage well the
third if the 35-year mortgage has been
done recently first off get as long-term
mergers you can get as cheap as you get
now why rates are where they are because
remember by and large outside of your
house which i realize is 90 percent of
your net worth negative interest rates
low interest rates is an unfair tax on
working-class people your checking
account your savings account you get no
juice in it there's no way for you to no
way for you to to to accumulate any
capital you're continually on the
treadmill while the larry thinks the
world why do you think they're going
around saying hey you're not going to
own anything you don't need to do
anything we'll own it larry fink's going
around they're buying up all the
apartment complexes buying up all the
houses to rent it back to you so on your
income you pay for it and they get the
they get the increase in the asset value
you'll have no privacy you'll own
nothing and you'll be happier more than
ever that's their policy that they've
been pushing and since the beginning of
covid i always said the thing that's
going to hurt people the most is not
this virus but the economic consequences
of these larger moves that are being
made because it's not only the
devaluation of the us dollar it's not
only hyper printing the federal reserve
just giving their friends all of their
money in in the hedge on wall street but
it's also the destruction of the global
supply chain and the global economy
which is being eviscerated right now
right in front of our eyes and there's
no fixing it and it's only going to get
way worse before it gets greatest
concentrations of wealth in mankind's
history was the was the result of the
solution for the financial collapse
brought on by wall street and and and
their guys in washington dc in 2008
right the solutions for that and what
happened with the ccp virus those are
the two greatest concentrations of
wealth now you have a a one percent that
what owns 40 or 50 of the country here's
the thing if we don't start to
restructure this and to get more
capitalist into america and that means
every person is a capitalist every
person gets a piece of the action
this system as we have it now will not
survive it cannot survive because the
only way it survives is they got to keep
printing money and they're about at the
end of that i just need to point out
because you can't see it on the camera
or those are just listening that every
time luke starts talking and getting
into it steve just likes pointing at him
like this is my anarchist this is my
aunt this is my anarchist now
welcome to the light side
we're gonna we're gonna enlighten you
about government not being involved in
our business
let's talk about uh well well um
um i guess i guess on this issue what
one thing that's always hard for me to
answer that's why i asked about houses
is you know what regular people have to
be worried about i think the obvious
thing is the price of your groceries you
know so i've gone to um you know i was
at the grocery store recently and i
asked the lady who's doing checkout how
price has been and she's telling me it's
it's insane it's crazy we've got you
know i hear from more and more people uh
talking about how they go to the store
and they're they can't they can't afford
it anymore so this is what happens
you've got people in these big cities
who vote in someone like joe biden
because the media colludes to to to prop
up a narrative to protect him to do
whatever then they don't know what's
going on they're ill-informed for me
i'll tell you what i want
i want regular people to have their own
agency in their own power i want them to
know as much as possible so they make
the right decisions so i don't got to
worry about it you know it's frustrating
you know i'm driving down the street and
i see a guy and he's you know he's
pushing a wheelba a wheelbarrow but he's
backwards he doesn't know what he's
doing and i'm like that's frustrating me
guys spin it around grab it by the
handlebars your life will be a lot
easier then i don't got to worry about
you screwing something up for everybody
else but what's happening with the media
the things that oliver darcy points out
is that regular people are confused and
wrong they thought trump was the problem
joe biden the bite administration the
remnants of obama 3. 2.0 or whatever
that is the problem it was the problem i
recognized it then and we're seeing it
now i want to take this inflation thing
let's let's use this as an object lesson
on their smugness and arrogance and i
want to tie it back to what he just said
we now have a remember
when guys like peter navarro and steve
cortez on the war room every day and
we're the first ones to call the
pandemic back in in january 2020 which
shifts the show those guys came on on
the day that biden took office i said
hey we're you look at this guy's
policies we're going to be heading into
1970 stagflation which is slow growth
and inflation they're the first guys to
start talking about and and and uh
cortez is a guy in the pits is a traitor
and and uh navarro is a phd from
harvard's economics department top in
the country right and i know guys laugh
at him but he's a damn good economist
they said this is not gonna be
transitory because now you have the
double whammy they've juiced the system
and they even sit there larry some of
the guys said we should have never done
that interim we should have never done
that last 1.9 trillion that we did that
biting those guys passed in the spring
we shouldn't have done that so now you
have the worst of both worlds you have
what is called uh demand poll right and
cost push because of the broken supply
chains and the structural problems that
navarres has never been dealt with from
the ccp virus and particularly because
in china so now you have a double whammy
that's not transitory it's baked in it's
six eight ten percent right and that
think about it with wages increasing
just at two to three percent in
inflation at six to eight percent that's
a five to six percent absolute tax on
working-class people they're getting
eviscerated right now and and remember
ron claim the chief of staff of the
white house 90 days ago said these are
high-class problems right these are
high-class problems right i saw that
from the progressive left i said the
same thing cnn said inflation is good
for they try to sell this it's great for
rich people
rich people let's go to darcy's thing
this that article right there is
brilliant brought that up that is the
single best example from oliver darcy's
own network if you look at that article
it's a joke they came out the other day
and said hey what nobody's getting here
in the messaging is that inflation is
actually good for the poor and bad for
the wealthy yeah did you see the i mean
that's that's insane
but this is this is they don't respect
working-class people enough to have the
common decency to sit there and go hey
here's where we are here's what we're
trying to accomplish here's what it's
going to be they just want to continue
to brow beat you over there with
information war to make it seem like
it's your fault well that's because
they're robbing and stealing them
there's an old viral uh old snl skit
that's been going viral and i think it's
dan aykroyd who says you know during i
think it was during carter inflation's a
good thing don't you want to own a 5 000
suit wouldn't you like to own a five
hundred thousand dollar car i know i
would
smoke a fifty dollar cigar that's
actually kind of a question i have for
you steve maybe you can answer maybe you
can't um if you have a hundred thousand
dollar house the economy gets inflated
by fifty percent the house naturally is
worth 150 000 now just due to account
inflation at what point if you keep
inflating the economy does the house
become worth zero or does the house's
value no longer it's not worth 100
million anymore like at what point do
you inflate more money about the value
at the at the point where you can't
people can't afford to finance it right
you're gonna have an asset bubble this
is okay
one of the things that president trump
did let's go back to 2008 which you know
from the occupy movement when um when uh
obama came in and they had the balance
sheet was 880 billion dollars and his
guy said let's inflate the balance sheet
the fed just put we'll just force cash
into the system to save the system to
prop up to prop up assets okay you had
an asset bubble that was increasing when
trump came in in his first two years of
office with a three percent growth he
actually took a trillion dollars off the
balance sheet of the federal reserve he
actually shrunk it wasn't quantitative
easing it was kind of
quantitative tightening okay and that's
one thing he never gets credit for those
kind of growth rates
low inflation with not unjuicing the
system was an act of heroism now
powell when powell came in and mnuchin
and these other guys we started to put
it back on you've got you know the
balance sheet of the fed i think it's 6
train or 7 train today because of what
the ccp rises besides that's that's over
and above what the national debt is so
my point is wall street always wants to
inflate their way out of here the
problem is you get an asset bubble and
then people can't afford it and in the
real economy can't keep up you can't
don't have people that have jobs and can
start to afford your hundred thousand
dollar house it's now a million dollar
house so you're kind of getting into a
vicious circle and this is what people
probably this is the problem people have
right now the
the um
zero hedge has a great article i think
it's from birch gold um the guy's name
brandon smith i think it is is on zero
hedge today it talks about the coming
collapse right and the coming collapse
is when they gotta stop printing money
because in printing money remember it's
on the backs of working-class people
you're gonna you or your kids are
eventually gonna pay this off because
they ain't painted off right so that
that's why it's gotta be
certain things go up and particularly
like housing and some of your assets
your asset value will go up now it's
about can you get priced out of can kids
today because you have no capital you
have no ability to accumulate capital
how do you get the down payment or you
don't have a great enough job to
actually make the the mortgage payment
you're paying for it already with the
dollar of being in the value and let's
let's let's jump into the black members
my anarchist economist right here we got
uh we got some news i mean uh so the
first story that we saw about elon musk
was that he was saying people gotta have
more babies and then steve you brought
up that he was like yeah and he also
said he's gonna implant chimps chips and
people not chimps chimp chips
in people he did it to a monkey first
once i got the story from daily mail
elon musk says neural link could start
implanting chips in humans in 2022
people with severe spinal injuries would
get the tech the billionaire says could
help them walk again
that's the charge yeah that's the trojan
horse we're going to save the guys with
the paraplegics and it's all it's that's
part of it's all great okay but but this
neural link is quite dangerous
two tv shows i want to reference as we
get into this
outer limits and stargate uh sg1 in
there's an outer limits uh episode where
everyone's got a device on their faces
that connects them to the stream of data
but the stream is a collective uh
essentially that it's an ai that
effectively controls people's minds but
they think they're getting clean
information they think they're they're
being shown the truth so they act upon
what the information they're given is
although it's seeking to protect itself
in stargate sg-1 they go to a place
where everyone's slowly dying off and
they're all you know connected to this
like ai system that erases their
memories as people die so they don't
know what's actually going on wow this
is these are the dangers of what you
what you get with like a neural link
there's i i don't think this is true but
i was told the lore of the borg and star
trek third show is that they were like
regular are you familiar with the
concept of the borg no
they're an alien uh in star trek the
next generation they fly around these
big cubes and they say you will be
assimilated resistance is futile
they're they are cybernetic they are all
one hive mind and they implant you with
chips to sync your brain up to their
machine and the idea i guess was again i
don't know if this is actually part of
the star trek lore but this is what i
was told they were regular people
developing medical technology
just like us and they started implanting
more and more and more until they
started connecting and then the natural
process by which they connected their
minds created a hive mind naturally so
we look at what elon musk is doing and
he says we're going to heal people how
long until
it's twitter but it is on steroids
you've got everyone just marching in
lockstep behind a tribal ideology this
is why facebook went to meta look you
have the convergence
of
a bunch of technologies that are
happening here advanced chip design
which is neuralink you have artificial
general intelligence which is artificial
intelligence that kind of recreates
itself you have regenerative robotics
you have crispy advances in
biotechnology the convergence of those
in a couple of other industries are
converging on this point called the
singularity on this side of that point
is homo sapiens on the other side of
that it's let's say it's homo sapiens
plus okay and and this is
hey on climate change in in all that is
that an immediate crisis
i don't know i'm not a climate change
denier but i can look at the evidence
and don't know if it's absolutely as
immediate as they say the immediate one
i can tell you
is this crisis of we're coming towards
this because there's no regulation on
this once again your audience has to
understand
as happened with shipping all the jobs
over to china it's your money the great
the greek tragedy part of this
everything about the singularity is
financed by the pension funds of the
deplorables in this country it's it's
they're they are the venture capital
front remember the venture capital firms
the private equity firms the hedge funds
it's all your money from your pension
funds from your from insurance companies
from your banks that's the money's done
and what they're doing
is coming up with uh with the
convergence of this that
who knows you know they're going to be
designer who knows how this goes it is
hurtling so fast and now this is the
thing about schmidt in that report if
you read kissinger and schmidt's book
they're telling you
well guys hey guess what we don't have a
we don't have a choice here because it's
an arms race the most dangerous weapons
in the history of mankind are being
developed right now in artificial
intelligence oh by the way the chinese
are here the russians here so we have to
get into this arms race so now you're
going to have this exponential growth of
this in 30 years there's going to be
some 18 year old who's had a neural link
since he was born
and he's going to be like what's the big
deal i mean we've always had the chip
we've always been implanted the okay at
front national uh national rally the the
political group in france uh in january
of this year they they had their annual
meeting at kickoff meeting and they had
a bunch of french thinkers come up and
address them about what's happening in
the economy what's happening in future a
guy stood up one of the top biotech
investors in in france and said
the um
the first
post
homo sap full homo sapien has been born
today and they will be something that is
post man okay because of either a chip
artificial intelligence is a planet who
knows my point is if you look at it
you've got all these industries going
down this path totally unregulated with
nobody looking you've got darpa your tax
dollars you got private equity you got
stuff happening in china south korea in
in eastern europe nobody knows what's
going on right and but you're seeing
hints of it you're hearing hints of it
from the schmitts of the world and from
people talking about national security
saying well you know there's some
artificial uh intelligence weapons that
could be you know very scary got the
hype people are sitting there going you
got the guy came out the other day on
the defense department saying we're so
far behind where the chinese are okay
then you don't even talk about the
crispr part which could get to the
biological weapons we have no earthy
idea what's going on we have no ability
to control it right now because look i'm
a fighter and i fought globalization and
i'll take on a lot of fights this one
right here you just kind of sit there
and go where do we even start why would
the elites want the plebs to be in their
neural link network they don't here's
what it was jane goodall said the other
day is that they they um
she said the other day the caring
capacity
their mentality
is that
because you can't solve the global cri
the math doesn't work to solve anything
on the climate change crisis at the
scale you have of people today of seven
billion people okay her thing was hey
the carrying capacity of earth that's
correct is 500 million so what the at
least
what's what the elites want is 500
million right and so they say the
replacement strategy it's not about
whites versus hispanics versus blacks
it's about homo sapiens versus the
elites want and all of them focus on
this one thing which is life extension
right
veritas the veritas guys when they were
in the facebook that facebook you know
he's talking up the young girl and being
a big shot and talking about how they
work the election against trump the last
part of it's the buried lead he goes oh
by the way all zuckerberg and the white
spend their time on is living his
eternal life and met adversity he's the
one that dropped the bomb on meta that
they're going to a whole different thing
of the embodied internet and that's
where they spend the time this you make
you make a big deal about this election
they don't spend any time on that they
really spend their time on this the
elites in the world are spending their
time now financing and looking at
extending life because all of them are
godless they're all atheistic
materialists they want to live forever
okay they're in back of this whole thing
and this is not a conspiracy theory
there's not conspiracy theory look at
look at facebook in meta and they have
enough power and influence and money to
do so and it's not just countries but
steve it's not just foreign countries
it's amazon it's google developing
artificial intelligence also working
with china in order to do zuckerberg
google these are like we're back in the
uh in the middle ages we have city
states yeah amazon and google and that's
why i'm a radical populist in this these
companies immediately have to be taken
over immediately have to be controlled
like public utilities they have to get
seven percent returns they have to be
under the control of the people of this
country they have to be controlled like
the regional belt operating companies
were back in the in the 50s and 60s the
bell thing they have to be treated as
public utilities you cannot let a
handful of people okay on the
deplorables money remember zuckerberg
these guys had no cash in the beginning
this was all their money now these
companies are out of control to me meta
before you get to the embodied internet
we ought to understand what the embodied
internet's going to be to the people
look at the ad they have at this this
meta ad you see with the the metaverse
medivh you you talk about mankind being
asleep and just sleep walking through
life you look at that that that ad that
ad is like oh we're gonna enter we're
gonna entice you into this new
living new pod living and you're gonna
be you're gonna be totally asleep this
is the sleep of mankind did you see the
suicide pods assisted pods
in switzerland no yeah
elon musk even even has monkeys with
brain chips that are playing video games
right now as we're speaking as the world
economic forum literally just released
the statement with one of its
representatives talking about how we
need a population of the world that's
that was 500 years ago 500 years ago the
population of the world was 461 million
people and they're talking about
overpopulation according to all the
world's problems
this is not some schmendrick this is
jane goodall now she's been saying it
forever but she says they answer what's
a base and i've heard this from people
they they call it the carrying capacity
of the earth they've run the numbers on
this this is not i'm not conspiracy
theory guy this is something they work
on all the time and you can see
by these different technologies it
shouldn't be lost on people when china
went to the when the ccp went to 10
years ago made in china 2025 which they
never talk about anymore because they
realize they got people's attention that
the top of the top 10 industries they
said they're the 10 industries they were
going to dominate by the year 2025 the
top six
were the industries that converge into
the singularity okay crispr advanced
chip design artificial intelligence
artificial general intelligence robotics
robotics
regenerative robotics
this is happening today this is not
science fiction we've hired by the way
guys at uh war room john joe allen runs
a team right we're adding more people to
it just to focus on transhumanism
because i keep telling people set
climate change off the side that maybe
maybe not who knows okay but this is
real and this is going to happen not in
50 years not in 30 years in 10 years
i think you're going to hit the
singularity what does that mean that
means you're going to have the ability
to have a post homo sapien either
between neural link artificial
intelligence a combination of
biotechnology
what does that mean for our lives what
will we experience people tapped into
the system the system that they control
yeah exactly first off you're going to
have somebody that you're going to have
your kids are going to be competing or
could compete against people but that's
um
beings that are just not homo sapiens as
as we know it right people that through
their own native intelligence hard work
diligence but have either have chips in
them have artificial intelligence have
biological have been biologically a
change somehow right through crispr or
other technologies
that are in designer designer
species that are over and above now
how's that supposed to compete in in in
in in college in education for jobs all
of a sudden you're you're not you're in
a different you're in a species that's
not the highest species
right so you're you're a homo sapien
there's a homo sapien plus now i realize
a lot of people say bannon's lost it but
no no no no no no no no you're
absolutely right because i've been
researching and studying this thing for
20 years they're laying the groundwork
right now especially with the future
that you're talking about where you're
gonna have to have a government-approved
medical procedure to be a part of
society and you will be kicked out of
society you won't have a good social
crisis or unless you have that if you
think i'm crazy if you think i'm crazy
go to every pr let's go to every major
private venture capital firm in the
country on their annual meeting where
they put up their deals well steve you
look at their deals in technology and
artificial intelligence and machine
learning and biotechnology it lines up
to one of these verticals and these
people will tell you these verticals are
converging they're converging to a point
called what ray kurzweil kurzweil who
was thought of as a nut case when he
came up with this concept 20 years ago
kurzweil the singularity he's the evp
of research and development for wait for
it google okay these are the guy
deepmind you've got some
obviously the smartest guys in the world
are working on these things and they're
converging and this is a crisis that's
building up because this is the kind of
thing like how do you even regulate it
how do you how do you how do you govern
it how and so all this science fiction
has been written about
this is now science fact
look elon musk who's
people that know him will tell you
maybe not the best manager in the world
but he's one of the top engineers in the
world when that guy comes out and says
in the fall of
2022
that would be less than a year away
i'm going to be able to insert a chip
into a human mind okay a human mind
that's going to take care of somebody
who's been apparent no spinal cord is a
paraplegic that's where it's going to
start okay but trust me they've got
stuff in the neurolink lab right now
that ain't just working on paraplegics
it started with the monkey controlling a
video game with the chip implanted in
its head and there's a reason a lot of
the top globalist a lot of the top
corporatists are eugenicist believe in
population control and ultimately are
transhumanists who want to transcend the
human spirit the human energy into their
own form of reality where they control
every aspect of it that's all
essentially the end game it sounds crazy
but there's a lot of insane
technological advancements that we don't
even know about that we should be
talking about that
i can't believe i'm saying this i'm i
believe in anarchy should be some
regulations surrounding oh no no no no
no no no it has to be regular first off
we need this can't believe i'm saying
when eric schmidt came out with this uh
i think 800 page report about a year ago
on artificial intelligence that he had
done for the defense department and he
had done it on on on trump's watch
he signaled right there that he said
we're in an arms race and china is so
far advanced and you've heard guys come
out since then including the people at
the pentagon that are in charge of
representation saying say hey we're so
far behind all of a sudden you get into
an arms race on this thing it's your
nuclear weapons you started at something
at nagasaki and hiroshima that was one
thing and now because of the perfection
of it right think about it for a second
there's
more computing capacity in that phone
than there was in the kennedy space
center when a man went to the moon
that's the other thing is they got a
fact
joe allen there's an analysis out
by a guy i think he's at mit enjoy
apologize don't get right
moore's law which is the driver of the
of the chip that goes in your brain from
elon moss is moore's law every 18 months
the computing capacity is going they're
going to cut into a size and it's going
to double whatever every two years
computer power doubles doubles it's
about 18 months that's moore's law but
two years
in a.i
the guy did the analysis in a.i joe
allen's fact got it up on warren.org uh
a summary of the article he said hey
they've got a moore's law on artificial
intelligence but it's not doubling every
18 months it's 6x yep it's potential
growth that just goes up dramatically
you know what the event horizon is
when ai gains the ability to code itself
artificial general intelligence because
you have artificial intelligence and
regenerative robotics when it codes
itself as artificial general
intelligence now some guys will tell you
that's a fantasy it'll never be able to
happen there's other guys that say hey i
think we're on the glide slope indicator
for like 10 years
my point
we don't know but what we do know is a
massive amount of capital of your
capital of people's capital is going
into this and it's not being discussed
darpa
your tax dollars to the federal
government okay your all these
universities everybody goes to are
massive research labs for this remember
the university of north carolina was one
of the biggest testing groups for uh for
the
starting the ccp virus and nobody knew
what went on at chapel hill okay there
are things at every research university
in the country tremendous amount of
resources on your tax dollars and all
your all of your pension funds are
fueling this right now eli and nobody
and nobody talks about elon musk drops
this thing out whoa look at this and
it's always some goodwill thing which is
fine this is to help paraplegic people
and people can never move we're like hey
look trust me that's the first thing
they're leading with they've got a whole
raft of r d internally that ain't just
helping the the people that are that are
crippled yeah sure and bill gates is
working on digital contraception that
you could control for a button for
people's convenience sure and and bannon
gets an incredible amount of government
money but it's also being financed in
another way right now when you have the
largest uh sorry
sorry sorry not bannon but musk you will
be an incredible muslim
but there's also the largest transfer of
wealth in recorded human history
happening right now taking money from
the poor and middle class and literally
being transferred to the billionaire
class that's building the prison
building this online technocracy that
we're going to be living in
one of the reasons we're doing
transhumanism i said this in a speech in
italy uh a couple of years ago
i said look
globalization came about because all
these forces kind of came together and
nobody stopped it and nobody talked
about it it was all supposed to be great
and turned out not to be great it turned
into have many more
more bad things happen then good things
happen and that's why you have the
stripping away of jobs uh you know what
happened in the united states all the
factories leaving et cetera
transhumanism is the same thing except
it's to the tenth scale because
globalization you can start to unwind it
it's tough but we are unwinding it to a
large extent throughout the world
transhumanism once you hit the
singularity and you're on the other side
of it you can't put that genie back in
the bottle the only point i make is that
there's so much research going on and
you got to avoid the thing of conspiracy
theories and and you know half-baked
ideas just look at the verticals
just take the chinese what they try to
dominate take those same verticals look
what's happening in the united states go
to drudge i mean drudge has got one of
the best transhumanist sections now it's
all over the page you got artificial
intelligence here you got robotics here
you got things but if you look at just
the news every day that's coming out and
that's only going to accelerate it's
going to accelerate at an accelerating
speed and we need to get ahead of that
we've looked at each other now they're
going to celebrate it they're going to
they're going to create that neuralink
chip which is going to grant you access
to skyrim don't you want to be the noble
warrior fighting the dragon just implant
the chip and plug on it baby well the
company the companies building it are
the ones already helping influence
elections so when we look at google when
we look at amazon we see them already
controlling the minds of the people we
see them controlling culture we see them
controlling entertainment so of course
they're going to build a support system
that's going to have people saying yes
please inject me with this latest
they're going to create chips where i
can read it's read-only so i can read
everybody's brain i'm basically part of
the collective i can read the internet i
can read everything then they're going
to have a certain class of people that
can't afford or whatever they're going
to have right chips where you can write
on their brain any of us in the class of
read-only of our elite class can write
on their brains and basically mind
control them if you opt out this is like
the vaccine manager if you opt out
remember they're trying to make you an
untouchable right now if you're
whether you're an anti-vaxxer or vaccine
hesitant or vaccine resistant okay
they're trying to other you
across the crowd look what's happening
in austria
things that would be conspiracy theories
in the summer are now facts austria says
everybody that's on vaccinate is gonna
be locked down then we're gonna lock
everybody down oh by the way on one
february mandatory vaccination for the
entire nation germany says the same
thing it's going to happen we're going
to put it in front of the bundestag in
early february mandatory vaccinations
things people would say oh that's bannon
and tim poole and all these crazies
these are all facts coming together now
so if you opt out of if you opt out of
the singularity
from a moral or religious or spiritual
point of view
if you think that's going to make did
you the vaccine mandate look like a
kid's like a garden party did you see in
sweden they're already implanting chips
in their hands i saw that what they that
that could just be some trendy people
trying to you know but it is true but
but
it is but it's a it's a it's a it's a
beta site test that's what they're but
they all the stuff's going to be
basically
the vera chip thing for over a decade
how long has it been like if you combine
it all if you look at it and then you're
gonna have a bombshell oh by the way
in uh in in in the fall of 22 we're
gonna have the ability to put a silicon
chip
right in your brain
to make the uh the people that can't
walk and can't move will be able to do
all of their functions think about that
for a second what we have not been able
to do with medicine and that's just the
first amendment you're gonna see these
announcements here's here's the issue to
elaborate on what ian said about read
only and write he's act it's actually i
think what he uh may be missing is that
it's not gonna be that read only is
available available for the people you
get your neural link chip there's going
to be police chips the police are
granted a chip that can read your chip
it's not about whether you you think
they're going to give you
the ability to read someone else's
private info no no the authorities will
however walk up and say what are you
doing here ah that's a lie i can see it
i've got a read chip then there's going
to be high ranking elites with the right
chip which can change what's in your
chip and can shut you out can show you
down law enforcement might be able to do
that but imagine if every venture
capital firm had a public presentation
and went online had a public
presentation and say here's where our
investments are here's what these
companies look like in five or ten years
here's what the technology's gonna be
developed the american people would be
shocked
what's going on here who approved this
they won't need tasers ever again
if they can give you the ability to
connect your spine they can certainly
interrupt that signal can't they
so the police officer walks up and the
person tries to run and then also the
person just stops dead in their tracks
why because the police have brought have
the ability to you know through
bluetooth within certain range disable
motor functions if the chips can grant
it certainly they can interrupt those
signals
is that a possibility i think it
certainly is i don't know about in 10
years because they got to get everyone
to view this as normal first that's like
that's why i said in 30 years they're
going to be some 18 year old who's like
you guys why are you complaining
whatever we've always had our chips i
mean how many people make videos today
where they're like the government is
forcing us to register a number with
them in order to live and work and get
access to public accommodation this is a
violation of our civil rights nobody not
a single person is putting out videos
complaining about social security
numbers so in 30 years not a single
person will be complaining about the
singularity they'll be in it and they'll
be happy they'll also own nothing
when putin's talking about weaponizing
artificial intelligence i don't think
many people even realize or understand
or could even comprehend the ways that
it could be used against populations so
that's one way one basic way there
you're explaining it but there's
multiple personalities when you have an
intelligence that is higher than you
higher than any
smart person in this entire world and
when you have that capability when you
have that power how can you control it
how can you stop someone who's a
megalomaniac from wielding it that's the
real question that i think we should be
asking ourselves especially with the
consequences someone someone said it's
been two years and there are already
camps in australia no due process you're
taken from your home you are placed in
the camp no due process let me say
another thing about many of the
scientists and technology
technologists that are in these
different verticals
also understand the deep
moral and ethical problems that they
face i think it's dr
doudna who the book um isaacson's book
that won the uh pulitzer prize i think
she won the nobel prize i think they
wanted to pull a surprise the book about
her in crispr
her book
the book she actually wrote that came
out before that book was her doubts
about and questions
about bioethics so people in these
different areas there's many people
right now that are very concerned and if
you talk to them off the record
right they're very concerned about where
all this is heading whereas the benefits
may be tremendous in combination or
where we're heading hasn't been thought
through yet what do you think about the
mark of the beast
what do you mean the mark of the beast
that you cannot buy sell or trade
without the mark of the beast it's uh
from what revelation is that yeah
yes i know the apocalypse well i didn't
know that um you didn't know that you
didn't know that i didn't know the buy
seller trade i just assumed like my my
general understanding without having
looked into it was just that you know
the apocalypse would happen and people
have this mark and then someone
mentioned with the market you could not
buy sell or trade unless you you know
had the mark of the beast and i'm like
okay that's really specific that's kind
of crazy right
although i do think there's been many
you know instances i mean nazi germany
for instance where your papers where
they've implemented some kind of mandate
but you know people now in in the chat
are alluding to well that's the vaccine
passport yeah the vaccine passes an
entry level entry level part of that but
it's social credit scores social credit
scores and the results you have a social
credit score here right social credit
score here that's why you're deeply
that's where you're de-platformed or
de-financed and de-banked right
anybody's considered an insurrectionist
or anybody to consider anything with six
uh january has been de-platformed are
they look donald trump let's
he's starting his own social media
company now because as
commander-in-chief before he's out of
office he was de-platformed by the
social media you know miles told me
years ago he said
as powerful as nuclear weapons are
social media
is 10 times more powerful and the
chinese companies party know it that's
why they decapitated that's where they
made 19 they made a decision to go to
their own technology companies to start
to control these companies the west
that's why they eviscerated the tech
companies back in the spring of this
year where i think it was 600 um billion
dollars of market cap that was lost of
american pension fund money to get
control of it so we live in an era of
social credit scores that's that's not
theory that's practice and yeah and it's
also with the esg with major
corporations and it's also with another
corporate social credit score that
people don't even know about with
corporations leveling you giving you a
score on on not just what they could
sell you but your beliefs and your
systems as well look new york city just
came out the other day de blasio said by
december 27th that's in what three weeks
there's gonna be mandatory vaccinations
for private companies and and children
from five to eleven are gonna have to
have a pass yeah they're gonna have to
have a passport to get in basically any
function and indeed did you see the
prime minister i think in new zealand
said this will never end i think you
tweeted that yep um
what's her name jacinda or something we
got to go to super chats though we gotta
go we're gonna go to super chats take
some some questions from all you guys
who've been super chatting away so don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to the channel we're gonna
have a members only segment coming up
around 11 or so i can only imagine that
will be fun and spicy so let's uh let's
read what we got
all right let's see i see a lot of
people keep uh demanding that i mention
fjb
uh which i gotta say uh there you go i
mentioned it fjb the the the crypto or
whatever
i i i i actually find it uh we get so
many people trying to pump for their
pump and dump scams with with with crap
coins we'll keep it ish coins that's the
newest so i get it you know it's funny
to make fun of joe biden but seriously
like people who want to come on here and
try and pump whatever coin of the day it
is to try to make money off of
i'll take your money with your super
chat but i ain't going to read it
because this is not what we're trying to
do we're trying to have serious
questions so what what what are they
doing with the uh what are they doing
with the coin
no i i just jp it's literally a trash
coin like a sheba
the purpose of it is if you don't like
joe biden buy it it pumps or whatever
and people are trying to pump and dump
so there's a whole bunch of these like i
mean fine you can do it people are
basically playing a game of hot potato
they say hey everyone buy this buy this
thing and then people do and then people
sell out it's really interesting to have
a hundred million people be like hey
let's all buy poor people be like let's
buy this and they all buy it and then
they all sell it and make money off of
it
they don't all sell it make money yeah
not all
what kind of scheme is that so long as
everyone keeps pumping it you don't
gotta like the sec has made it illegal
with stocks i would imagine right
well let's talk about what's really
going on here's an important one from
eric johnson tim i made a jardinera
pizza like you described it last night
and it was great huh fjb there you go
uh you know what jardiner is no it's
like uh i don't know what it is
vegetables pickled vegetables little
spicy jalapenos and it's a big thing
pickled pickled vegetables like
cauliflower carrots jalapenos okay and i
think celery too i don't know yeah
and i they put it on sandwiches and
stuff i love putting it over a pizza and
baking it just so good
all right let's see what we got pizza
again
we got punisher gaming cause i've really
enjoyed watching tim slowly red pill
himself by by passing out red pills
never get high on your own supply i love
you guys we don't always agree but truly
search for the truth you have my respect
hey appreciate it man
all right dim sum nim sum says we are
hoping for funds to help the obvious
financials oh okay this is about uh the
other one here dim sum says hoping you
will shout out and share my sister's
gofundme she has thyroid cancer we're
hoping for funds to help the obvious
financials she will she'll need to need
to pay because she has she'll be getting
ionized radiation treatment interesting
um
i suppose i could shut it out but
there's no information to shout out but
uh you know sorry to hear it man good
luck
all right charles balzian says don't
forget about erdogan in turkey the lira
is soaring higher than the dogecoin
turkey has full control of azerbaijan
and syrian militia when times are bad
war comes watch out for turkey yeah oh
yeah
a great nato ally
oh i guess people are saying that fjb is
being used to uh donate to two people to
veterans yes bar league says fjb the
official cryptocurrency of the let's go
brandon community love steve bannon and
tim poole 50k donated to veterans in 40
days
all right all right all right so i i
apologize well i think i think i think
you can take the transaction fees off of
these things yeah it can be quite i
think that's what they're doing they're
using it to uh in that case oh hey guys
shout out to fjb sorry for you look we
get so many you see all sudden all
sudden you just you turn so quickly we
just get so many people who are like
scam crypto scam crypto so i'm like here
we go again we got people saying you
know whatever but if it's how could fj
how could something name fjb be a scam
that's a deeply rooted that's a deeply
rooted primal scream yeah agreed
all right joshua schrader says hey tim
as you know i didn't know this the new
fj b coin cryptocurrency or maybe
someone brought this up before and i i
forgot about it has been doing so much
for our veterans but did you know
they're also teaming up to launch the
first decentralized media blockchain no
more censorship from tech tyrants god
bless all right well there you go all
right i like donations you learned
something new every day yeah i'm on the
website let's go brandon coin dot io i'm
looking they say what they donate to
veterans but i'm trying to find out
exactly what's getting donated i think i
think i think
on the trade there's a transaction fee
right when you do it i think a part of
that transaction fee goes to veterans oh
chris b says steve as someone who wants
to be more of a bookworm do you have a
list of books to read for those of us
who want to who want better
understanding of the world and history
yes yeah should i give that yeah yeah
let's name some books what do you think
um
the first one i'd read is a bridge and
maybe i'll come back and give it to you
the bridge version of uh decline and
fall of the roman empire gibbons you got
to reinvent the extended versions a
little long you definitely should read
that
uh i would read the uh i would read the
best and the brightest
about the kennedy in the in the in the
vietnam war definitely read that i would
read um
i'm trying to think there's so much
stuff great stuff to read
if you want to read about a tremendous
individual
right i think the greatest president
we've ever had and probably the greatest
individual we've ever had in this
country lincoln
you can read gore vidal's novel lincoln
about how people make tough decisions
under under tough situations
also there's tons of um
there's a great book on geopolitics by
mckinder you ought to read that just
basics of geopolitics of the world
island and central asia and how central
it is to how critical it is to kind of
world history so i think those are two
or three right off the bat and i'm
trying to think about something in
technology or ai that i could recommend
right now
to read i'll think about that in a
second but there's so much to read and
artificial intelligence and economics
and all that that's very important today
all right fnp says steve do you believe
china's obscure
and fraudulent financial structure can
collapse and what is the geopolitical
implications of a collapse in china
uh absolutely i think it can collapse i
think it shouldn't be last year i think
it was uh
grande today went outside the 30-day
window of making their uh
their interest payment on the bonds
china's is a house of cards even more so
than the united states and the federal
reserve and the bank of england and the
whole
judeo-christian wes's financial system
china is to the fifth power they just
continue to kind of print money right
and they keep it going and they live off
of our dollars four trillion dollars of
u.s capital if we cut them if we cut
trying to offer our capital markets the
chinese countries party would collapse
in 90 days now unfortunately our
financial system would also take a major
hit an implosion that's why it has to be
kind of a
level down of these gangsters but no the
shadow banking what you're seeing in
china is absolutely incredible and
here's the thing remember the chinese
people the lao beijing the these noble
people of china old hundred names save
50 cents of every dollar they look work
a slave labor but they save 50 cents
every dollar because there's no social
there's no social safety net
that capital has been basically
exploited by the chinese communist party
they're the first people are going to
get wiped out in the implosion of this
real estate market that's where you've
seen these videos you have the table of
the company and the people are coming in
and women are sitting there with knives
up to their throat saying i'll slip my
own throat right now unless you give me
my cash back or
show up with the real estate because
i've lost everything so the chinese
people are going to be abused here but i
100 agree with him that it is a
completely phony system totally they
manage every number there everything
they tell you to the west is an absolute
lie and larry fink and all these wall
street guys have done nothing but put
american capital which is basically the
pension funds of the united states in
there to finance the stripping of our
what i call the stripping of the altars
right to take all the high manufa value
manufacturing jobs over there and and
now to prop up their real estate market
all right dawson
jackal says you might as well take the
money i was going to spend on vodka and
food denied service and entry for not
showing vax passport welcome to china
wow and our new national anthem
oh china this is our leader's land in
true communist love all of us bow down
with cowardly hearts we see the rise the
true north weak and slave from far and
wide mao keep us safe and remove our
rights oh china
we deny your human rights yeah it's
crazy what's happening in canada justin
trudeau by the way even publicly came
out and he said one of the things that
he likes about the governments in the
world one of the things that sticks out
to him is the economy and how it's run
in china and he looks up to the way that
they do business there which is
absolutely crazy and mind-blowing
there you go man he's beyond the
manchurian candidate
all right let's see of course of course
his father knows something about
communism whoa i went there
i went there i went there i was thinking
it
went there ltg says i work for nato in
nl russia will not invade ukraine
well they not good so it's all just a
distraction
ben hairston says forget gold buy
chickens they taste better yes and what
are you gonna do carry around gold as
you wander from from outpost to outpost
no the chickens follow you put them on
little chicken leashes you know and you
just make them walk
they walk themselves they'll walk and
eat at the same time
all right raymond g stanley jr says hey
all steve at first i didn't know you now
after irl sir you are a populist and a
dang good one at that also why are you
wearing three pens
it's code prepared
so
day three pen day a lot of people said
uh after you're like the first second
you were on what's the third time you
joined third time a lot of people i was
in the old place right the other
students i was in the other studio
we've had a lot of people say that the
only the only thing they've ever heard
of you was what the media had been
saying about you and then to actually
hear you speak and hear your ideas they
were like
wow was the media lying and i'm kind of
like do you watch this show because
that's all we basically just say that
all the time the media is lying so of
course people actually hear what you
have to say and they're like this guy
actually doesn't sound far right at all
like the media certainly tries to claim
it i mean you said it but when you talk
about taxing the rich or the one percent
or whatever that's just populism it's
kind of like centrist
i'm more than just tax the rich i think
we have to have a a um
to think about a reallocation of assets
and resources and that's leftist that's
not leftist because i'm a here's the
problem with american capitalists
american capitalism there's not many
capitalists
a a right-wing or a what they call right
or a center-right populist
believes
the central part of this is everybody's
got to have a piece of the action
right the problem we've had over the
last 40 50 years is that too much of
returns have been to capital and not
enough to labor and so the people the
backbone of the civic society that keeps
people say well the united states the
capital markets are so robust you know
people want to buy in the bonds they
want to buy the stocks and i go why is
that and so it's so liquid i said well
what causes liquidity what's so safe
well it's not the security exchange
commission our laws and regulations
which are very good but there are other
security
laws and security laws around the
country it's our civic society it's the
underpinnings of the safety and security
of the united states of america and
that's every cop every teacher every
nurse everybody that coaches little
league that provides this thing called
america that is this this this sovereign
nation right
that security that civic society the
thing that every day you see people
going to work and kind of self-organizes
that has not been
they have not gotten
enough of the piece of the action that's
why people have been here you know
10 generations nine generations eight
generations and right now you're sitting
there with you know fifty percent of the
families in this country can't put
together a thousand dollars in cash
money okay half the household households
in this country i think still eighty
percent of people's net worth is tied up
in the whole in their equity their home
that has to change we can't have this
concentration where our founders
the framework the framers of the
constitution the founders that fought
the revolution was against an arrogant
landed aristocracy both in parliament
and in the crown okay they would be
stunned and shocked to come back here
today and see that we've turned into an
oligarchy that we have basically turned
in to
almost like russia with with the tech
oligarchs the oligarchs on on on wall
street and now they're paid servants in
washington dc remember those guys are
just paid they're just on the payroll
yep they don't have any power powers in
the global corporations in tech and in
wall street and they control these guys
and that's what we have this country
can't go on like that because i keep
telling people you're going to have some
socialist left-wing inefficient debacle
where you're just getting tip money or
we have to go to a system that everybody
has a piece of the action and that we
have controlled labor markets that
people the wages can rise if we do that
and people get peace and get prosperity
america's on it could be on the verge of
of a massive renaissance and that's
within our boundaries to do during
occupy wall street there was around this
time period there was a document that
was that was made by citigroup
calling america plutonomy
they said it's no longer uh you know
constitutional republic it's a plutonomy
where the wealthy control everything and
this was like a serious document
outlining how the country works and then
we saw other data that says
the opinions of the general public have
zero bearing on the votes of members of
congress now i've seen that yep this is
why one thing i would go back to world
economic forum and they're they're
advertising in marketing where they say
you're not going to own anything and
you're going to be happy right kind of
is in space
i would like to have a system where you
are going to own things called assets
you're going to have real assets like in
real estate you're also going to have
securities and stocks you're going to
actually have ownership you know we talk
about and the guys on the left all the
time
and i too about to carried interest you
know going after carried interest on the
private equity firms the carry you know
starting to tax carried interest
i want to have a different system i want
to have the american people each
individual has a carried interest in the
nation has a carried interest in the
economy of the nation
not just by the way if they pass build
back broke and all this other stuff but
that's what the davos says they say they
want everyone who's a stakeholder in our
system to be actively involved but they
don't want you to own anything they'd
say it right there you're not going to
own anything you're going to be happy
you're you're just not you're just going
to be a part of the proletariat right
you're just going to be a working staff
and what's going to happen until they
get to the time that they can go homo
sapien plus and then you're going to be
unnecessary and i think harriet tubman
was who said i have freed many slaves i
would have freed many more if only they
knew they were slaves
they take away your ability to
understand what you don't have and you
won't crave what you don't know exists a
french uh a french poet who died at
verdun in the early days of world war
one it was a devout catholic and he had
this great saying he says it's not for
us
to report what we see
it's most important for you to see what
you see
that is the important thing in your life
today to see what you see take the
blinders off look at what real reality
is once you do that you'll be in
solidarity of people that want to want
to change the system change a system
in opposite of state-owned socialism and
communism and marxism but to to true
freedom marty smith fan he's got he's
very on point with this one he says i
became a tim cast member today because i
appreciate steve ben bannon and that
third hour is must see war room posse in
the house wow that's right
members of the love of posse
you know
fjb baby
in the events uh the website it was
basically us being like we need to
expand and we need to be we need to have
our you know preparations to be
independent from any of these big social
network sites to have our own website
you're like citizen kane
you're like john foster kane or whatever
it is charles foster kane you've got an
empire you've got an empire seriously
all the tim cass people i came here
and the old studio was fantastic it was
great but
it's not what i'm sitting today i mean
this is like it's growing this is this
is super upgrade yeah it's not easy
though man you know we're navigating the
minefields trying to make sure that
there's the conversations that we can
still have and then you know effectively
social credit score which always think
about what you said when tim paul
who you've got a lot of scars in combat
experience in in this whole movement
from the occupied days and you were in
ukraine i was in venezuela venezuela
you've been in some tough stuff
think about it for a second
and you're not
crazy you're very reasoned you've got
some
some ideas are out there but you're very
reasonable when you start every
broadcast
and you think i gotta watch what i say
on these topics
they're winning that's the system we've
got to get away from because we've got
as a country that's that's push that and
push the envelope we should leave the
battlefield because it's dangerous and
this is what's really frustrating to me
and i talked with this with alex jones
about this i said
the right is losing because they're
reckless and they have no tact they are
they are saying i'm gonna go out into
the middle of the battlefield with no
strategy and no plan for how i confront
those that oppose my ideas and then they
get wiped off the map in two seconds
and so as much as there there is an
issue with we need to be able to talk
and have these conversations there's
also the the complete knowledge and
understanding that youtube twitter
facebook are key areas of a battle of
ideas and information and when you are
confronting ideological opponents on
that battlefield if your ideas i'm going
to walk in right in the middle and yell
out exactly how i feel don't be
surprised when you're no longer part of
the equation but i like that movie the
patriot with mel gibson a whole lot
because what does he do as one guy with
his two kids ambushes the british and
and takes on massive amounts of the
battalions because he thinks about what
he's doing first so let's think about
what's happening you've been banned from
youtube we haven't yet i've been uh here
has been banned in perpetuity from
twitter but here you are getting out 99
of your ideas so as long as we try to
maintain you know navigating the
minefields in this battlefield we can
make sure that 99 of the ideas are still
able to persist and then for the ones
where we are actually dealing with major
cur you know curtailment we can always
set up our own independent website and
make sure people like you get your you
know ideas out to the best of your
ability people know where to find you at
war rooms no no but i i got that we
should and that's smart you gotta
strategically do it but we shouldn't
have
these social media oligarchs who on the
public's money remember if
zuckerberg had no cash he was living in
a storm in harvard well peter thiel gave
him money
he would put 500 thousand dollars my
point is and peter thiel's money wasn't
peter thiel peter thiel was
institutional money all of those guys
when they write you a check it's a pinch
it's a cops fireman nurses teachers
money it's a pension fund's money it's
called institutional investing
they take they take a one or two percent
management fee and 20 percent of the ups
that say they make money off their fee
structure that's the carried interest
that's not taxed as ordinary income my
point might be
because yes but they shouldn't have the
ability
tim poole should never have to walk into
this show
ever and think about is there a topic i
can't discuss let's take alex jones for
a second you know actually people say
this that the other thing
i just take one topic
if you go back and look at what alex
jones has said about transhumanism
alex jones has been ahead of the curve
for this thing for what for 10 years
easily alex jones was talking about the
topics we talked about tonight
10 years ago which
when the history of this age is written
people are going to focus i think on
that right and see who who are the first
guys to call it out and and one it was
alex jones and alex jones is banned
everywhere yep maybe for other
activities my point is that
some of his stuff
has been absolutely groundbreaking okay
for all the madness they say alex jones
has you go back and look at the signal
not the noise
the signal has been very strong on some
of the most important issues facing our
world today
right
i mean your stuff's amazing but that's
and people get into it it's it's it's
it's out there and it's not being
covered
to think that the mainstream media and i
talk about that they don't they don't
have major stories and connect dots not
just say oh you know elon musk neural
links and he says oh yeah we got to have
babies the same time but are connecting
dots of these technologies we we we
should get uh let's talk about the
member segment because there's a lot
more i want to say but i have a lot of
super chats okay so i think we can do a
big conversation with this so everybody
we're gonna have a really uh serious uh
strategy discussion in the members
segment that you should you should check
out not to cut you off or anything but
there's a lot of really good super
examples check this out we got a really
really good one and you know i may not
agree with the initial sentiment here
because i've been ragging on alec
baldwin a lot i think alec baldwin yeah
he shot that woman you know and he might
get away with it but uh i want to read
this one brian cohen salman says i stand
behind alec baldwin 100 percent
standing in front of him is too
dangerous
all right all right all right block
vikings says steve what do you have to
say to a former bernie bro who doesn't
agree with the corporatisms the gop has
historically embraced and dnc seems to
have picked up either way let's go
brandon
the populist movement inside the trump
movement taking over the republican
party is anti-corporate we are we are
very anti-corporate here's the thing
you're getting played
remember the most progressive president
in history president obama
during his watch was the greatest
concentration of wealth in the nation's
history because of the economic
decisions made the democratic party is
100
bought and paid for it owned by
corporatists and wall street all of you
progressives out there you're being
played okay and that's why a big part of
this movement going forward is former
bernie bros that wait look working-class
hispanics african-american men and
bernie bros are the future of this
populist movement
and combined with us and the reason is
we got to break away from the
corporations the corporations don't have
your best intentions in mind look at
they're the oligarchs they're the ones
deep platform remember i keep telling
the republican party guys and i rubbed
their nose in it i said you created this
monster your tax cuts and your
deregulation and now you're sitting
there whining that they de-platform you
you and your policies created it and
that's why and look i
admit i'm on a
i'm on this on the when you look at the
spectrum or the range of alternatives
i'm a little bit on the hardcore part of
this but that's why i say in silicon
valley particularly in social
media i'm for total digital and data
sovereignty
okay that's why i think things like fgba
fjb and other these coins have to be
looked at here's the reason
they've forced you to do it they've
destroyed the us dollar they have a
printing machine up there in capitol
hill right now tournament seven trillion
dollars you owe it to yourself to look
at
your own digital sovereignty your own
data sovereignty your own ability to
participate in in not just in
cryptocurrencies but in other other
either stores of value okay you owe it
to yourself today because they're not
going to do it
i would tell the bernie bro we are the
anti-corporate part of this we're a
workers-based working-class party and
that's why you see in the rio grande
valley they're supporting trump that's
what trump was the weapon trump was the
armor-piercing shell that went through
this right he and he gave him blunt
force trauma why do you think they hate
him he was pro he's a billionaire he was
part of that whole system he'll tell you
that they hate him with a pathological
hate that's almost uh and the reason is
because he's the armor-piercing show let
me tell you
paul perry wants to know if you're going
to be involved in the next trump
administration you know after he runs or
when he's running
well let me say it this way in 2020
the war room
we are dedicated and maniacally focused
on building the trump movement and when
we say the trump movement taking over
school boards having people become
election officials taking over the
republican party with populists with
people just going as precinct committee
men we are a firm we're
i think the biggest supporter of the
president uh i you know if to agree that
we participate in the campaign like we
did in 16 i don't know time will tell my
biggest focus right now
the mantra we have right now is 100
seats 100 years we can win a hundred
seats in 2022 and govern this nation for
a hundred years through the house of
representatives okay and after that the
republicans gonna do anything
this is why by the way republican party
since 1968's won more elections than
it's lost in a process lost the country
you need to have
new people new blood and new policies
and i think you're starting to see those
people come up it's always going to be a
fight and that they co-opted the tea
party movement it's it's our fight every
day to fight this and to focus on it but
no i think president trump not only is
he going to run i think he's going to
win and i think he's going to win in a
big landslide to the degree that i could
ever be of assistance i will always be
assistant but right now
the war room is the war room is where we
do it i want to i want to make a point
to say a lot i see a lot of people are
signing up as youtube members but uh
that may be a mistake if you want to
watch the member segment it's at
timcast.com go to timcast.com uh
otherwise you just as a member
supporting the channel which is greatly
appreciated for sure but again
timcast.com that's where we're going to
have the the you know the bigger
discussions and everything like that but
all the supports greatly appreciated if
i'm if i'm you know making a mistake i
just see you know a lot of people have
just signed up
so all right let's see
civilized age custom says if
corporations replace workers with ai
eventually there won't be people with
income to buy their goods and services
they go to business
so i is that is it is it is that going
to have an impact on this
on the transition it's gonna it's gonna
it's gonna no it's
they won't slow down because of that
problem right they're looking to first
off
cut their cost
by doing as much of this art if you see
this everywhere i mean
particularly in china they're trying to
use as much artificial intelligence and
robotics as possible to take out labor
cost so their first their first issue
will be to get to get rid of labor costs
i think they'll deal with the second
part it's it's a it's a great point and
like i said a lot of this would be a lot
of this is to be thought through but
right now we can tell you when you look
at look at party look at the party of
davos the fourth industrial revolution
when they talk about the fourth
industrial revolution how much humanity
is in that when you look at the fourth
industrial revolution and what they're
talking about that's going to
participate the human element of that is
is looked at as inefficient right and so
they try to extract that so no it's a
great point uh it's got to be thought
through but they're going to look at the
cost side first do you think universal
basic income is part of this too
i think that's universal basic income is
part of the fourth industrial revolution
that because i think they're gonna say
hey you're gonna be have a job but we
gotta give you x amount of cash right
but we don't we don't but that's not
what people want people just don't wanna
be paid some stipend some tip money
you're more you're more than you're more
than a that's where you go from slavery
to indentured servitude no you're not
indentured servant you're not going to
live off the tips and the scraps of of
the elites of this world they're going
to pay a universal basis where they're
going to pay a couple thousand bucks a
month so you can play video games and
just vegetate no yes you're a human
being you're a you're a temple of the
holy spirit act like it okay we're not
gonna we're not gonna we're not gonna do
this i gotta i gotta issue a correction
because they say uh you will own nothing
and you will be happy and that's that's
incorrect that's incorrect you will own
many things like the forest leather
boots of agility or the mythical tiara
of the dragon queen you will own a
little digital home you will have your
virtual space you have a license to
those things yes
there you go whoa shut your power off
you're gonna have that's why you have a
wingman you're gonna have your little
server space where you buy your little
house and you're gonna show all your
friends your digital little house you
built in fallout 3 and everyone can or
fallout 76 and they can come hang out
there and be like wow
but you know that's one of the things
about this like that's why if you notice
today people's aspirations are getting
tinier and tinier and tinier and life
like tinier and tinier and tinier
go back and look at the folks that built
this nation right they came from
everywhere look at what they
accomplished with so little to back them
up right right for me
and i'm talking working-class people
that came and built this country that
unbelievable a vision i i have
i view myself as having a very similar
vision you know wanting to build an
empire and you know find the secrets to
immortality and eventually uh create a
singularity in which i will be i'm
kidding hey there yeah
you got to be thinking here looks like
wait wait where's my anarchist bring my
hannah kristin
luke and i had a joke like what almost
10 years ago that i was like you know
you're going to be the corporatist i was
going to be confronting you outside of
your own building
look i got your placard in the suv you
can start progressing i'll be 50 walking
out of a press conference or like flying
to bilderberg and then luke will run up
and be like tim you know you were at a
meeting in yangon get out of here luke
god but they're going to they're going
to try to co-opt you they're definitely
100 they will what are you talking about
the way the system the way the system
does it but how does how was some kind
of knock at my door and be like hi i'm
with davos
eventually eventually somebody say hey i
got to meet i got to meet tim poole and
you meet tim paul and said man if you if
you had a hundred million bucks and back
you could go you could do this that's
that's a it's cooperating but they call
this i'm not saying you're going to take
it but
you're you're getting at that scale
that now you people notice you everybody
talks about the tim full show ever in
the right aubry i know possoba navarro
everybody cortez did you see tim poole
last night i got to tell you my cfo she
won't let me mention her name she's
fantastic she's a temple addict in fact
she she flew back she flew back from our
from our other office to be here tonight
because she's a she and she's as
right-wing as you can get she's a temple
but somebody's going to come to you
eventually and say hey look with 200
million dollars you could expand you
could get off no i couldn't
i literally couldn't i've had people
offer me money but it's never been like
hi i'm an institutional investor with a
million dollars i've had people be like
a couple hundred grand what would that
do for you the answer is nothing yeah
the issue is not money for us but a
couple hundred million dollars could
change your life can make things it can
make you grow much much quicker maybe it
doesn't but i'm saying you're going to
get they're going to try to come and
co-opt you and the first thing i say you
know what you know luke is great but you
know luke is out there sometimes and
maybe luke ought to be in the back and
writing this is the way they do it
they'll try to co-opt you they're trying
to take the edge off they don't like the
edge i don't see it happening through
investment i think it's it's more of uh
there i'll put it this way there's
literally zero there there is no money
amount that could make this better but i
will tell you we've got two 501c3
nonprofits one for creating
decentralized tech to make people
uncensorable and the other is to fact
check news organizations as well as our
own
outlet and the fact checkers themselves
so we're going to be going to people and
being like would you like to donate to
our 501c3 tax deductible and stuff like
that that's a potential avenue where
they might want to put money in but
that's a separate entity outright from
whatever it is we're doing here so they
can certainly get involved with a
nonprofit help build technology i guess
but if someone came to me and said 200
million dollars right now
and we would buy x or we would do this
i'd be like i literally have no idea
what to do with that money and it's not
going to change anything we do we've
already we we've gone through project
pitches and i'm like the problem is not
money for us granted it's i'm not trying
to act like we have 200 million or
anything like that it's just that
finding driven passionate talented
people is the is the challenge money
doesn't solve that it doesn't i've been
through it it doesn't solve it you just
got to build it up slowly over time
rough around the edges and you slowly
get something like we're in now look at
you notice the lights around the edge of
the room we've we've gotten rid of
studio lights we've done a new thing
with led strips it's just you know
people come to me and ask me how did you
build all this all up and and i'm just
like one step at a time it's not like
this this thing where we sat down and
did all this crazy research and funded r
d it was literally like hey you know
what i noticed our lighting sucks
and then we had one guy be like you ever
see these led strips and i was like look
at that
and that's how it happens if someone
came in and said here's 200 million
dollars have a good time i'd be like
that literally won't get us anything we
can need i mean i suppose i could buy a
skyscraper or something like a big
building go buy a cable tv channel why
would i want a cable tv channel
because you get up you get off youtube
then youtube then you can talk about
anything you want
right now you can't talk about anything
you can't talk about anything you want
to talk about cable channels sure you
can
you need to talk about anything you want
but we'll let's do this let's uh we're
gonna go to timcast.com
200 million dollars we're interesting
well that's going to be your tv channel
we're going to no no no no no we're
going to test him i'll tell you this
i've been there somebody's going to come
to you one day okay somebody because of
the success of this and the impact it's
had somebody is going to come to you
with that size check i don't think so
that's i'm just that size check so when
this happens right then it's 7 december
2021 somebody will come with you to you
and there's going to be
there's going to be hooks on it the
hooks are going to be hey you know it's
kind of edgy you know can we do this can
we talk more about this but that's the
that's the faustian bargain you make
with capital
i just you know i don't think it's going
to happen i think any one of these
institutional investors who have done a
psych profile profile on me based on the
things i've said they're going to be
like that guy's too risky don't go
don't go near him you're not risky as a
businessman though you've you've built a
great business you actually know how to
mitigate remember the thing about
entrepreneurs that people want to know
is not are they risk takers you know you
have the energy driving forward the
motive force but do you know intuitively
how to mitigate your risk let's jump to
the tim kaine member segment so
everybody's watching go to timcast.com
sign up we're going to immediately just
jump start into this talk about
censorship co-opting
the deep state all this stuff we've got
a lot to say but we're i don't want to
run too late i want to make sure we get
this up for you so again timcast.com
sign up now and uh you can follow the
show at tim cast irl smash the like
button subscribe to the channel you can
follow me at tim cast steve where can
people find you
go to warroom.org that's we're on live
every day from uh from 10 to noon
eastern time and then at five to six and
you can go to war room you download the
podcast we got show notes everything and
we're on i'm on getter so you can go to
get her under a steve bannon to get her
so just go there that's the one site
i've got and we got the worm over there
so get her or go to warm.org and see
every day right on or or look at the
msnbc because every day they're taking a
shot at me did you see that photo from
the war room your show where they they
announced what was going on with the uh
uh with uh you and the oh yes yes
yes all right also tim uh you know don't
forget i'm here waiting to confront you
any moment any time uh
but that's a separate story
also a lot of people forget i have my
own media organization where i have
confronted a lot of the globalists and
uh to find out about that plus a lot
more sign up on my email list enough of
censorship.com enough of censorship.com
that's the one way that i can't be
censored and of course i have a youtube
channel we are change on youtube we are
changed hope to see some of you guys
there love you guys so much thank you
for coming steve always a pleasure my
man love love being here with you
gorgeous good to see you again lydia
thank you so much lydia thanks for
setting this up yeah i'm always happy to
have steve we really enjoy his presence
he's very wise very well-rounded so i
was uh pr instructed to ask you if
you've ever heard of the term kali yuga
are you familiar with this yeah sure
yeah yeah we're in the cat we're in the
california that's what rogan was playing
this we're gonna tell you well why don't
we talk about that later all right we
have to hold on to it okay i just had to
i just had to the joe rogan mentioned
he did yeah a couple weeks ago no no
we're in the cali right now okay well if
you want to know what that is you're
going to go to timcast.com be a member
and uh is that did you mention yourself
oh yeah i know you guys can follow me on
twitter at sourpatchlids all right
everybody thanks for hanging out again
for the 80 billionth time we'll see you
over at timcast.com bye guys
you